buddy hello hello i am back i'm so tired all right we're
just gonna go right into we're gonna call the girls yes i
was in korea i was in korea yeah no one could have guessed
no one guessed it but anyway let me call the girls and then
we start though i don't want to i know like some of the
girls already did their street that we're already talking
about the trip i want to talk about trip with all of them
there because it was we can't say what we were doing but we
can say what we were doing we can't say what we're doing
professionally there we can say what we're doing um visually
there so i know all the other girls were already starting
streams i'm gonna call them and then i need to set up um i
need to set up everything real quick uh all right i'm gonna
give Oh, I almost said video caught up, but Voice call So
I'm still so jet lagged, guys I'm so jet lagged I didn't
even save any of the photos I didn't even unpack yet, but
you guys know But like, are you guys surprised?
I have it unpacked And I didn't even Like, I have photos, I
just didn't Transfer them to the PC So I can do like a
little show and tell I'll do it live, I do it live If I ever
knew they would talk about Just show it on screen.
Like, you never unpacked.
That's what I'm saying.
Are you really surprised?
I also ordered a coffee, too.
They were like, are you guys ready?
And I was like, I need to order coffee.
All right, I am making... Oh, hello, Ryan.
Oh, I've actually made it so my audio was properly.
You're early.
You're the first one.
Oh, the shitties.
It's so good.
We're all late, but...
past the time we said we were gonna meet up.
I am, are you jet lagged?
I'm so jet lagged right now.
Oh no, don't even.
I'm.
I went, I went to bed at a normal time yesterday and that
was great.
I woke up at a normal time yesterday.
I, when I came, I woke up at 10 in the morning yesterday and
then today, 2 p.m.
No, it's not good.
I know.
I, I like, when I came back, I went to bed at a normal time
because I was so fucking tired.
And then today.
I slept at 9 a.m.
It's bad.
I was like, that's what I was like, let's do Monday, guys.
Because I was like, I feel so good.
We're all gonna have the energy for this four-way collab.
I feel so fucking good right now.
I came back and I slept at like 11 p.m.
and I was like, we got this.
Jet lag doesn't hit me.
And then, and then it hit.
Foreshadowing is a narrative device wearing.
And then, hey, Emily, hey, Mousy!
Oh, it's Carrie.
Hey, Rhonda and I were talking about how we are so jet
lagged right now.
We're not okay.
Actually, Jennifer Roberts is in my chat, too, and she's
also...
Oh, she's so jet lagged.
Yeah, I...
Today I slept at 9 a.m.
It was...
I thought...
That's why I was like...
But like, when I came home...
We are responsible adults.
Yeah, everything is fine.
I was telling...
I am in my life.
Like, Ren and I, we were like, on the first day, we were
great.
Like, we had a decent sleep, like, at a decent time at our
time.
Had, past tense.
And then that's why I was like, we should do Monday, guys.
Because I was like, I slept at 11 p.m.
when I got home.
I feel like I got this.
I beat jet lag.
Yeah, Stamon streamed up by the utterly deranged as it turns
out.
Don't worry, utterly.
We're all live.
I was just, dang.
Okay, perfect, perfect.
I just wanted to let you guys know that I'm lying.
Because I did that once where I didn't said and they were
like wait you're live and I was like oh you guys are crazy
man I don't know how you do it I thought I was I thought I
was stronger I thought oh no I'm weak no actually I will say
I'm too strong so we left Korea like our flight was at 3 p
.m.
Korea time we landed 8 a.m.
LA time I stayed up all day until 2 a.m.
the night before couldn't go to sleep I couldn't go to sleep
I
And so I actually did the reverse.
So I messed it up on the reverse.
I stayed up too late.
So I'm just like, because of my own power.
I'm like very slowly setting up a spooky right now.
Oh my God.
Yeah, I was too confident.
I was like, guys, we got this.
Because like, we were like, what day should we do?
Because we had to make sure the trip was fresh in our minds
too.
Because we just came back.
We don't want to wait too long.
But at the same time, like, gosh.
I was like, we've spent a lot of time on a plane recently.
It was my fault.
I was like, let's do Monday.
I was like, we got this, guys.
We got technically enough time.
Well, that's why I was like, oh, okay.
I have like, I can do Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
And I was like, let's do Monday.
I was like, whoops.
I'm sorry.
Rin and Mouse for being here.
I know it's like super early for Mouse.
It's super late.
Yeah.
No worries though.
I've literally been playing like Papa's Mo Korea for the
past three hours Hey, so here's I'm a real gamer.
Also a disclaimer for everybody.
We are not revealing why we were there Yeah, we can't say
why it's no secrets no secrets wrong answers.
We can't say why or we won't say why it's calm It's sort of
yeah, and also won't I don't want to tell you guys Yeah, you
guys don't get to know yet.
You have to suffer in silence.
What do you like to know?
Like yeah, no, that's why we tuned into the stream guys yeah
oh my god but we will tell all of our non-nda stories that
are cute and wholesome and also chaotic yeah we sat we all
sat in nda and we get caught we're gonna get shot in
minecraft yeah yeah whoever spills the game you die in real
life famously oh my god oh i don't even know where to start
i i i don't there were so many things oh wait well Massey
was here for this but I won we were we yeah nobody expected
math we were like this because like in the off collab we
were oh yes this is a we're like this thing is only for the
three of us or is that yeah we're like there might have been
a fourth secret member and everyone's like who is it I mean
we were talking about like the MCU or whatever I had half a
mind to just like say Iron Man and kind of let people draw
their own conclusions Iron what mm-hmm and then surprise it
was bouncy was there all along I wish we had your like
little figure for the photo booth we didn't have your little
your little guy yeah yeah that was the one time we didn't
have it we had it everywhere else it was just because we
didn't carry it obviously because We're the talents.
We went to importance to do things like carrying bags.
What?
We had a personal Iron Mouse carrier that carried Iron Mouse
everywhere.
And then...
That was her only job the entire trip.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And then coincidentally, she was not there when we needed
it.
Yeah, that one time.
That one time it would have been good.
Dude, one time we really needed a photo too.
The iron mask area was not there.
It was my proxy.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, I guess, like, well, this is something we were all there
for, but we went to the T1 facility.
You guys went to the T1 facility, and I was sick and had to
go back to the hotel.
No, that's so sorry.
We were, like, three days into the trip, and I was just
like, we're sort of self-destructed halfway.
Victorian orphan boy.
There's only so much I can do.
You were there still freaking out the whole time.
Don't go like, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Dude, I know nothing.
I know nothing about T1.
I don't know anything about esports.
But my face, I was like, no, I want to go so I can watch
Doki fan girl over like, Tessler trash can!
You!
Oh, my God.
They touched that handle!
This is the air they breathe.
They breathe.
Holy shit, he's locked out that window showing Faker is
here.
So, yeah, and then, like, there we were at the gym and then
the tour guide was like this is a private tour by the way so
we were allowed to go to places that were just like cool
yeah I know we're so cool but we're allowed places that
normally the public wouldn't be allowed so we get to go to
the gym and then the staff was like this is where faker does
his stretches you want to take a picture of the floor I did
take a picture of the floor I was just like oh my god that's
where this is where like faker makes his coffee in the
morning like holy shit i was so funny we were like get down
there do you do some stretches i'm refraining freaking out
okay yeah they're like dude do you want to sit they want to
sit on the floor where faker does his morning stretches and
i was just like i i'm not do it in front of like everybody
like i'm refraining like actually people in my channel like
who is who is this john that you're in my shoes so that you
understand what I was going through.
Oh my god.
As it turns out, this esports shit is serious.
So serious.
It's a no-world I just didn't know about.
I mean, he is the greatest esports player in the world, Rin.
And as I know now.
Damn, I am a larper.
Oh my god.
I don't know anything.
There was a- Yeah, me neither.
Oh my god.
I don't watch League of Legends.
The thing is, it wasn't even in the game.
our schedule for the longest time but the day we were flying
i literally typed in our chat like the what we were doing
chat i was like can we go to the t1 facility because i was
like wait that's in korea like it clicked in my head wait a
second we're going to korea and i was like wait a minute
wait this is literally in korea so and then um so they set
up a private tour within like 24 hours which was fucking
crazy and it was so funny because when they were asking the
rest of the girls so they wanted to go.
And I was explaining what T1 is and who Faker is.
And I was like, are we going to see Faker's tower?
And then Rin was like, is he a wizard?
What, is he a wizard?
You said from the back of your eye, could you see a wizard?
Faker's class.
It was so funny.
It wasn't even a wizard's tower.
I didn't even see any pointy roofs.
What a bother.
It was just the silence that followed like, are we going to
do this tower?
Silence, silent.
Is he a wizard?
Famously, yeah, that is what I sound like.
I can't even refute that.
Unfortunately, we did not see Faker's tower.
Apparently it was like miles away from the actual home base
and he had two towers.
I was like, and then we made a horrible joke about it.
And then we made a horrible joke about it.
But I said, never forget, I said, the kids these days, no
six, seven.
love to forget specifically that joke thank you yeah someone
was like like lord of the rings and then amelie jennifer
roberts was like thinking about lord of the rings yeah i was
thinking about 9-11 okay okay people have also been asking
me who jennifer roberts is i think some of my gang thinks
she might be another vtuber no she's a real person yeah
jennifer roberts she's my good friend and also was my
handler for for this trip but it was just your angler your
angle yeah my wrangler she was my my toddler backpack holder
um and by extension therefore the toddler backpack holder of
the entire group i'm trying to get jennifer roberts to
become a vtuber i want to buy her one of those like
customizable yeah i feel like we can do this we can do this
however we're talking about it and we're like what if like
instead of like an artwork it's just photographs of her and
you like just rig it so it's like a real person i mean like
people have done that we can find someone yeah it's so funny
yeah i want to get art of her as uh chris jenner jenner
because because jen anyways of like you're doing great
sweetie holding like the camera because she was like just
taking photos of me all week but uh no i think jen you'd
kill it as a vtuber she's also like an incredibly talented
like voice actor so she would kill it as a vtuber
my entire career and like you know all of that that's just
secondary jennifer roberts she knows so many people yeah she
almost dated sebastian stan who is like who's bucky barnes
in like marvel not marvel i was like marvel like yeah she
almost dated some crazy like she'll just like throw a nuke
every once in a while and i'm like what what like you worked
for who you did what what i mean you can't you don't have
room to talk doggy anymore because you've you've sat in the
same chair that they grab his breakfast presumably well
that's true i sat on the fake that's on the same level as
far as i'm concerned baker's chair too i did post that photo
actually yeah she said i wasn't sure if you were allowed to
post that i i mean where it feels about people just coming
into his office and sitting on his chairs someone was like
stolen valor wait i didn't even think about that i didn't
even think about What if, when he comes back and he's like,
these girls started my chair.
He was like, something's wrong.
Something happened to you.
That's so true.
He's gonna like, my chair moved.
Strange energy.
Wait, what, wait.
Obviously Doki's favorite part of the tour was Faker's
stretching spot on in the, in the gym.
What about, what about you, Mouse?
What was your, what was your favorite part of the tour?
Whoa, I, I just, the whole place just looked like you could
just live in there.
If there was a zombie apocalypse and it happened, like you
didn't have, you wouldn't have to leave.
I was so shocked.
I mean, you'd have Faker on your side, so presumably you'd
be fine.
That's true.
Yeah, I think, I think he'll live for the zombie apocalypse.
Yeah, the strats would go crazy.
But my favorite was the karaoke.
Oh, yeah!
That's true!
Yeah, so for those who don't know, oh, wait, wait, wait, I
want to see you explain it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, they have like their own karaoke rooms in there, and I'm
like, what?
Yeah, because they're too famous.
They can't just go to karaoke.
Of course.
Yeah, apparently, like, some of the players in the league
team, they love karaoke, but there's, like, no karaoke
places near the headquarters.
So they literally built, like, fuck it.
We'll do it ourselves.
Yeah, they built two karaoke rooms, four of them.
Yeah, it was two booths, remember?
Oh, yeah.
It was, like, a solo karaoke.
Like, if you're losing too many games, like, a solo need to
go.
Oh, no.
It's herself up and it's like a group karaoke room.
All of them was an impressive one because I was like, oh,
who would do karaoke by themselves?
I was like, oh, I guess I need to take my camera.
Sometimes you see that me time.
Yeah, you guys don't...
It's not our last coping strategies.
Wait, you guys ever watch Eggersuko, like the Red Panda
office lady?
Oh, the San Marawani.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And she's like seeing heavy metal.
Like, I'm just thinking like they lost too many Elo and they
just go into karaoke and just scream their hearts out of
like, Wait, song of choice to like hype yourself up if you
really needed to like, to like really get your, like your
Elo back and you're like, I have to sing one song to save my
Elo.
Frank Sinatra's my way.
Oh, hey.
Bangor song.
Bangor.
True, true.
Wait, and then there was a disco ball too.
Do you guys remember that?
Oh, we had a disco ball.
I gotta get a disco ball from my booth.
We asked the staff if we could turn it on and he was like,
oh yeah, he was like, I think it's broken.
They rocked out too many times is what that means.
They ran the battery out.
That's crazy.
What about, Rit, Natalie, what were your favorite parts
about the T1 facility?
My favorite part was the cafe that I had to spend time in
before going home.
Because I didn't go on the tour.
Because I was sick that day.
Yeah, but hey, you got free drinks and food, though.
Yeah.
Is that great?
I like that little, they have a little mascot guy.
It's like a penguin also.
Oh, yeah.
I got no problems with that penguin.
Yeah, yeah, they bought you.
They bought you one of the penguins at the store.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, this is news to me.
Yeah, yeah.
I haven't received any penguins.
You know.
You could have.
I guess I got to fly back tomorrow.
I requested a penguin.
I was like, I need to have one of those penguins, please.
They're so cute.
Oh, yeah, that's so true.
What about you, Amelie?
I think my favorite part was definitely you standing in
Faker's room going, I can smell the victory.
I'm soaking it all in.
He's like, yeah, I'm breaking it.
I was like, I really have a tournament next.
I needed that.
I have a tournament next week.
I needed that win.
I just got so good energy real quick.
Though I will say I turned to like their like, because like
each of their rooms has like like PCs and I was like, is
this a three PC setup?
Yeah.
And the guy was like, yeah.
And I was like, I thought I was crazy for two.
These guys are using three.
What do you need to do?
What do you need the third one for?
Yeah, so I think it's like different countries.
No, so it was- It was basically one was for the game and one
was to stream on Billy Billy and then the other one was to
stream on the Korean streaming site.
I don't know what it was called.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
So that's why they had- Yeah, that's why they had three.
But then they had like portable air conditioning.
They had like the building air conditioning and also
portable air conditioning because it's so hot in the room.
Like, yeah.
Three PCs?
Of course, I would, yeah.
Three PCs.
I can only imagine.
Yeah.
Though I will say my favorite, favorite part.
Can we talk about your shopping trip?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We can talk about my crazy shopping trip.
That was my favorite.
Because I was like, there is a shop too.
And then, but the main shop was closed.
So we had to travel like, I think like 30 plus minutes to go
to the second one.
She wants you to serious.
I lose track of Jokey after like, I lost track of everyone.
I was like, what's this?
What's this?
I turn around.
Doki has like, like, you can't even see Doki because of the
mountain of stuff that she has in her arms to purchase.
I was like, is she Doki?
Hello?
Where, where, where'd she go?
I bought a lot of stuff.
I, I thought I might, I might have spent, okay, to be fair,
to be fair, to be fair, to be fair, Avalie and Ren spent a
lot of money in a different store, but the league store was
mine.
The team That story was my special day.
I'll give you that.
All right.
Yeah, Emily, how much money did you spend on what's Olive
Young?
Olive Young?
I probably spent around like probably $500 because actually
me and Jen went back to Olive Young.
Yeah, yeah.
To a different Olive Young a day later.
To buy more.
Yeah, that's really like me going to a Sanreal store and
buying everything.
I have to ask.
How?
manage that like a hundred dollars sure i understand two
hundred dollars i'm worried for you see a therapist 500 is
getting a bit excessive treat yourself treat yourself yeah
treat yourself that would have been like like i at the first
that's not answer my question okay no no hear me out hear me
out the whole store was 70 off and everything's cheaper so
like you still spent 400 you still spent 400 imagine it
wasn't 70 off imagine that Well, in America, because all of
that would have been imported.
So like, and Olive Young just opened in LA, but it wasn't
70% off.
And also, you have to pay for the import fee.
So like, everything's more expensive.
And we got bags free, like, with our flights.
So I was like, I'm just going to, I'm just going to have a
whole suitcase of it.
I'm going to use that before it goes off.
I bought like two, like maybe like a hundred or 200 face
masks, like so many face masks.
Oh, yeah.
And then a lot of them were gifts.
They sold you that many.
Yeah.
yeah literally yeah it's so many and then i actually bought
more because i was like oh i'm gonna get it's tax free so
you can go to the airport and get off that's true that
actually work for you guys because i tried doing that and
they were like go to the booth to claim like your 20 or
whatever booth was closed oh yeah it's a little bit of like
uh because they don't want you to do it because it would
yeah they also only give it to you in usd or like japanese
yen yeah so i was just out of luck.
When I went, the line was too long.
So I was like, I guess I'm donating to Korea.
It's like $40 or whatever it was.
Oh, save the economy.
We actually almost missed our flight, me and Jen.
Oh, really?
What do you mean you almost missed your flight?
We, because the boarding pass was in Korean.
So we thought the board, like the leave time, like the plane
leaving time was the boarding time or the bird end time.
So we were the last ones on our plane.
Yeah.
Oh dear.
door when we when we got in i was gonna say it like how do
you almost you were there so early we shot ones on the yeah
like more stuff adam and i and uh jen and zoe we all went to
the the airport at the same time yeah and zoe and i like we
had a little bit of time it was a bit tight for us but i
yeah because oh no it could have been worse we went shopping
yeah we heard them leave first so i was just like how did
you almost miss your flight your flights later than wait a
second But it's okay because I at least had time to get
Korean Dunkin' Donuts, which as far as I can tell is exactly
the same as normal Dunkin' Donuts because I've never had
Dunkin' Donuts before.
Oh, you should have got like crispy cream.
No, you never?
Oh, wait, is there no Dunkin' Donuts in the UK?
Let me actually check that because I don't think I have to
see.
I think we have some, but they're very like few and far
between Dunkin' Donuts.
Oh my god, next time I come to the UK, I'm going to bring
Dunkin' Donuts to you.
Crispy cream is better.
Yeah, crispy cream is so much better.
culture.
That makes sense.
I know like crispy cream is better in Korea as well.
But I believe that there's just more food.
Should we have like crispy cream?
Yeah, yeah, there is.
We didn't go to crispy cream.
We did not go to crispy cream.
We did not.
We got to go back tomorrow.
Dude, everything tasted better in Korea.
It was so yummy.
That reminds me.
Do you remember?
I mean, maybe for you guys considering the the spice thing.
Oh, true.
Yes.
Happy for you.
Really?
I am.
however we couldn't handle spice so it was yeah so like i
was born in the 1600s right if i have anything with any
pepper on i'm going to spontaneously combust you'll never
see me again no i will teach you how to eat spice it's just
so good luck there are some things that simply can't be
taught to some people there was like one dish that the only
spice was pepper but it was too much pepper and rin couldn't
have it i think i taste pepper and spicy stuff the same way
because they didn't install my taste buds correctly in the
factory when they made me like i also barely have a sense of
smell so like take that for what you will oh no i just
wasn't built for this oh yeah okay remember like okay sure
we had an off collab and then we were eating food but we
couldn't say what food we were eating oh yeah it was oh yeah
we got spaghetti yeah it was because they got his kimpop so
obviously the moment like we're eating kimpop everybody like
i know we to like make up random food we're like we're
eating spaghetti right now because we couldn't see that's
what the East feeling all over the floor it was great so
funny accidentally dropped my kimbop everywhere we dropped
him off on the plate it wasn't not as bad as dropping
spaghetti and then I accidentally said the time out loud but
luckily we had been saying so like we had been like joking
around yeah we had been like we're saying random that's
unrelated to Korea.
So that's why nobody expected us to be in Korea.
At least the people thought we were in Japan.
No, I'm more of an Olive Garden guy myself.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
After you guys left, I was take, because I was the last one
to arrive and also the last one to leave.
Yeah, I was so late.
Oh my god, funny thing.
You know how I was, okay, so to you guys, they were like,
oh, you guys gotta wait to tweet your stuff until after you
leave Korea.
But then after you guys leave, they were like, to me, you
can tweet it anytime because I blend in.
Oh, I'm already playing.
I know.
I know because I blend in, you know, in Korea.
So they're like, okay, it's okay if you want to tweet
anything now that they're gone.
They waited for the white girls to go home.
I see how it is.
So they won't even see how it is.
They're like, well, she blends in.
That's hysterical.
Oh, my God.
They did have to keep ordering my tofu with it.
They like we would order, but they would order for us in
Korean.
And I'd be like, can you make it not so spicy.
Can you make it like- You kept asking for white- Wow, I keep
asking for love.
I said, I wanted spicy.
Well, because like the menu would have like multiple like
peppers on it.
And I'd be like, how many peppers is three peppers?
And they're like, that's a Korean menu.
So it's spicy for like some of us can't even eat that.
And I was like, can you ask for White Girl spicy?
And so they'd ask for character spicy.
I also I might have been a really bad person because I
fucked with Amelie and I was like don't worry this is not
spicy but it was no no it was so spicy and then it like the
spice stacked Amelie was not a scene again after that
fateful day oh god it would have a bite and you're like
that's not that bad and you have another bite and you're
like that seems doubly's bad like yeah oh sorry wait a
minute oh my god and then that one alcohol we drank where I
was on my second girls was like be careful with those.
The hangover is really bad.
And I was like mid-poor and I was like, what do you mean the
hangover is bad?
You tell me this now?
I'm on my second, like, I was on my second jug of it.
I was like, what are you on my head?
Oh no, I was so sad for you.
The soju.
Oh, no, it wasn't soju.
It was like, I've never had this one.
It's so good.
It was like, it starts with an M, like mock.
It was like some yogurt, milk, alcohol thing.
And we had the Ube version.
It was so good.
It tasted like a liquid donut.
That's all I can describe it.
Yeah, yeah.
But like I said, Rin was not there during that time because
she self-destructed halfway.
Yeah, yeah.
Famously.
Makali?
Yeah, M-A-K-G-E-O-L-L-I, however you say it.
And also, that was- Oh, Massey, you might not know this, but
that was also the day that Amelie and I were teaching we're
teaching the koreans how to shitpost so so so amali talked
to six seven you kept saying that like every i don't think
that was a single day amma where you didn't say that on the
entire trip yeah they were like what i think you said it on
the car drive to the airport as well they didn't know what
six seven was and then they taught me yaru first which is
like the like a kid's way of saying like that no no no no no
we were asking about like brain rot and memes and stuff and
then they're like i asked what a korean you're like you know
like six seven and they were like six
Is that what happened?
Yeah, that's what happened.
You were like, what are some Korean memes?
And you're like, you know, like sexed us in that country.
And you do that to them.
Corrupt them.
Oh, God.
There's actually a story that you guys don't know because
you weren't with me for like the last day.
But I was with a group of like maybe like 15 people.
Yeah.
And at the end of the thing that we did, I went, Yadu, and
one of the guys looked directly at me and then looked around
the group and went, Who taught her that?
So, for those who don't know And then one of the other girls
that was with us during that dinner went Six, seven!
And then the girl was like, oh my god!
I believe this is what they were taught to was being called
Sawa.
Oh god.
Yeah, so for those who don't know what the fuck Garu is,
it's like basically like a Korean shit post where like the
zoomers would say it.
So like it doesn't really mean it, it means like it's lit,
but like you know.
So I mean you should be old enough to know better yeah and
then you're being so not yadu right now good that was the
intention the international brain right she posting is a
universal language at the end of the day they did not just
say i really did not just teach them to say six seven she
taught no she told them she taught them the potion that she
taught them the had motions they were experience, baby.
It's a whole Fortnite emote, man.
I can't just teach them half.
Yeah.
You can teach them none of it, please.
We were trading.
We were trading information, okay?
It was a cultural exchange.
Yeah, exactly.
You learn something new every day, whether you like it or
not.
Of course, it's all Malita teaching.
We thought you were going to be the mature one of the group.
Come on, I didn't She's the oldest one teaching the kids
six, seven.
He's like, don't worry, auntie, I'm gonna do a teaching six,
seven.
Everyone ignore the white girl in the corner.
Oh, my gosh.
I was so, okay, I was so mad, like, back to the T1 store.
So I, since I spent like around 400 Canadian dollars, by the
way, believe what so 400 um the day after uh faker came to
the store like came to the the t1 pc bank the day after i
like we were not we left the store and i was so mad he was
so mad i was so mad because i was like i could have met him
god so much money they could have told me you know they
could been like, by the way, Baker's got Baker and his team
are coming to the PC Bay and you want to tomorrow.
He's coming down from his tower.
But they didn't.
Joki bought so much stuff they gave her freebies.
They gave them free stuff.
Hey, by the way, come here tomorrow because you're like
definitely a number.
You've spent enough.
Here's this little secret.
No, they didn't.
They did.
And then I had to find out via Twitter.
I was like, that was bad.
Why are they?
I was like, wait, I've been here.
I was like, why are they tweeting to this and i've looked
yeah yeah i think they're just pro they were like man if she
meets him he's gonna die and we can't have no i feel like
because we all have to be there going into cardiac arrest to
be fair i feel like we ought to be there because like oh
yeah because they never want us to be alone you know so like
we ought to be there and then we get caught so easily
because of all the cameras yeah can you imagine if like
someone was filming and then you just hear Doki's like very
signature laugh like in the back.
I love you!
You just see Doki in the back like, this is where he sat two
minutes ago.
Holy shit.
Maybe they were planning to be there the day that we were
there and they were like, actually you guys can't show up.
There's some mega fans here.
You can't.
Or maybe they were fans of ours and they were just too shy.
I couldn't believe it.
I was like, because I was like, I was like, I remember with
Jennifer Roberts.
I was just like, we were there.
We were there.
We're there.
You're like, those empty shelves are my doing.
I was like, I walked through this building.
I was here.
I am responsible.
Oh my god.
His throne is still warm.
Someone said it.
I mean, but one thing, Doki, one thing you didn't miss out
on, which Amber and I did, and congrats.
Sort of happy for you.
Yeah, so we found out that that was a Pokemon thing within
like 15, 20 minutes, I think, of our hotel.
it showed up on my tick tock feed like the the yeah they
were already ready to go if i'd known if i'd known yes so
i'm like donkey you were because you were flying out later
and you didn't have to get to the airport so soon you were
like sending us photos in the group chat being like okay
when i saw pikachu and here's what i'm just like so
basically um amalie rin and jen were all crying about how
they couldn't go there and then i've in the in the group in
the this server.
I was like, I'm going though.
I was like, I was like, hey, thanks for telling me I'm going
to go today.
I was so mad.
I was like, yeah, steal my ideas again.
Why don't you?
So I went to the, it was like, it's very tiny.
Okay.
To be fair, it was very small.
It was like, like a 10 minute walk over.
It's, you know, like there was a, you know, that Pokemon
park thing in Japan.
So it was basically a miniature size of that but like by
miniature oh yeah it was very miniature so it was literally
like a 10 minute walk from like front to back but still
would have been nice to see with my own eyes if this was the
case oh my god my chat is hosting that meme of the lion
yelling at the monkey because because I'm so mad at Jokey
for being able to go because I'm so mad at Jokey for being
able to go So you're going to find the picture that we put
in the server of the Pokemon stuff.
This group's going to fall apart.
Is we're going to fall apart before we're even allowed to
say what we were doing together in the first place?
All right, let me see.
Okay.
All right, but the...
Oh, what was it?
Okay, so...
But the thing is, I don't know if you guys know about it,
but they have these like little poke...
I remember in the Japan one, they have these like pokeballs
wherever you buy it and you unopen it.
any of the 4-gen Pokemon.
And in Japan, they limit that to one per person.
And, like, you have to line up for that for, like, two to
three hours at the Pokemon Park in Japan.
But the one here, I didn't have to line up, and I bought
three.
And you're going to give some to what?
You want to give one to us, right?
You know?
Who said that?
Who said?
Did you guys hear that just now?
Did you guys hear that?
oh okay but i did got karma so hard because at that i told
amalee this i dm there about this but at the pokemon park
obviously there was merch so one of the merch was like it
was two cans of soda um and it was so cute i'll post it in
the i'll post it in our group chat this doesn't end well
doesn't it doesn't end well so you guys know that was our
last day so obviously since it was last day oh that's so
cute can i share yeah yeah yeah so this also have a look
i'll put it on my look at that stream too so i was like so
excited because the cans were so cute this is foreshadowing
by the way it's so at the at the airport so it was like it
was like sparkling apple juice or something the other one
was coffee um i had i I have, I also bought the, I bought
the lollipops too.
So I went to the airport and then, you know, you go through
security and I forgot.
You're not supposed to bring liquids.
Oh no.
Oh, that's true.
And then, and then, so they were like, you're not allowed to
bring this because I forgot.
You're going to have to dump all of this down the drain in
front of us while we watch.
Just like, no.
And then one TSA agent was so happy you put it in the trash
can.
They're like, I'm going through that later.
Can I drink it?
So I legit opened both.
I took a picture of both of them.
I opened both and then just, like, took a sip out of both of
them.
So they couldn't, they couldn't take it.
So, oh, nice.
It's like, I was like, nobody knows what each other is.
I was like, nobody's getting this.
No one is.
Were they good?
They taste good?
No.
Oh, my God, for all this.
This is funny.
It's literally apple juice and coffee.
Ew, together?
No, no.
One was apple juice.
The other one was coffee.
Oh, Lord.
I was so spiteful.
I was like, I have, if I can't bring this, no one can.
So I got karma really hard.
Like after like, be like, hey guys, I'm at the Pokemon park.
And I should like dump the drinks I buy.
Not a lot, Neil.
I think in the chat, I said, I'm so sad for you.
the seas actually because I was so like my past messages
were so angry at you I was like I was like I hate you like
the whole yeah and I was like I'm actually like slash
serious oh oh okay so you know how okay you guys because
like you guys all left early so uh they took me to like you
know there was a bar there that would make drinks out of
your favorite character oh yeah it's in the photos server uh
and it was oh yeah it was it was so fucked up because
because since there was just like three of us the so we had
to we got like eight drinks I can share these right yeah you
can share these oh at large doesn't show the staff members
they said no it's just their hand it's just the hand wait oh
yeah yeah that one's fine the ones that those are fine the
one of the Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
So I had to be fair.
And then the one with your plushie, right?
We can show that one.
Yeah.
So to be fair, but the ones without like any like obviously
the staff in the background.
Of course, of course, of course.
Because like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They said just don't show that.
But like, of course.
Um, the crazy part was that I could have helped.
I could have helped with ordering your drinks too.
But so they're like, what two drinks do you want?
And I was like, Faker.
So I laughed out loud because Joki was like, we're here.
They won't play Faker's montage video.
Yeah, it was.
I just read it in your voice and it was so funny.
So basically, when you order the drink, there's a giant TV
and we happen to sit next to that giant TV and it would play
a song from the character of your choice so like so all of
us had like uh mousy was like i think the the cry for me one
and then um and then amalee okay i'll show you you last rin
was her newest dog mine was girlfriend and then amalee had
four songs playing i was like why the amalee fans let's go i
was like where's my faker song so i was waiting And I was
like, is this, so they, you know which songs they picked?
They picked the Has been Hotel song.
We're like, what hell of a team?
So, I was so, we were so confused because we're like, is
that Amelie's voice?
Because we thought it was like somebody's favorite character
was Alistair from Has been Hotel.
So, we were like, or the girl, I forgot where her name is.
So, we thought that.
And then, one of the staff was like, I think that's Amelie's
voice.
I was like, that can't be a Hasb.
Wait, there's a second.
That's that can't be That's an original song.
So, and I looked it.
I was like, Has been Hotel.
I really, it's the same video.
It's the same fucking video.
So, so she had four songs.
And then I was like, to the staff, I was like, can you tell
them why I don't have Faker's video on the TV?
Because I wanted the photo.
So, and then they asked them.
And then he was like, what?
do you want me to play and then because he was like we
didn't know what to play because they were really surprised
i asked for faker he's a human man yeah because he was a
grown human man so funny yeah and then i was like the thing
is okay i couldn't speak i had to whisper because one of the
staff members like at the bar came out and like spoke in
like perfect english to tell us that he was a fan of English
VTubers and he knew all of us.
And the alarm bells.
Yeah, and I was like, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring.
Oh, wait a second.
Did you like change your voice to be like really gritty and
like guilty?
I didn't say anything.
I like.
Oh, really?
That's cool.
I also love VTubers.
Because he was like, he was like, he was the main chef,
basically.
Because I was like, where did he come from?
Because I didn't see him at the bar.
But because he disappeared.
I was like, is he even a staff member?
Because he literally disappeared.
disappeared afterwards, but I realized he was in the
kitchen.
So, um, and then he, yeah, so he knew like Iron Mouse.
He knew like, I'm Lee Rin and I, because he was like talking
about like, oh, I'm so happy that Iron Mouse's health is
getting better and stuff like that.
And we asked him like who his O-she was.
That was so sweet.
It was also very scary.
Yeah, yeah, it was very sweet.
And then he was, we were at, like, the staff was like, who's
your favorite, who's your favorite ENV YouTuber?
And he said, do be.
And I was like, fuck, because I collaborate.
Yeah, you're like, yeah, the alarm bells get louder.
the sirens get louder and then he's like yeah i used to
watch her before and also now as duvy and i was like oh fuck
i'm in danger i'm in so much danger anyone so i have to
whisper to the to the staff be like i want them to play
baker's league montage but apparently all his lead montages
are like four plus minutes long so so they just played uh
they just played like some some league world's opening i
guess oh wait joki if you had to conceal your voice can i
hear what that would sound like no because everybody would
know what a fake voice i know you're going to point true i
showed you what it was when we're eating i know but i See, I
don't even bother.
I'm just like, well, if I die, I die.
No.
But there was like seven plus drinks on our table, and there
were three of us trying to drink seven.
Oh, this will stop me from the plane.
All right, so I remember everybody's drinks, I think.
And maybe, okay, I know like Amelie's was like milky.
It was a milky drink.
So it was milk coconut.
I don't know what fucking alcohol they put in there, But it
was like the milk out like it was a milky alcohol window
cleaner.
I presume Our mouse was Pomegranate because fakers was also
pomegranate.
So wait for the red.
So wait, can I show the one with the faker plush?
Okay.
Yeah, I was so cute.
Yeah, cuz I bought a faker plush like tiny little faker
plushie and also a giant faker plushie too.
So how much much do they have of this guy?
I was so much.
There's so much.
I told you.
I wasn't exaggerating.
She was holding so much merch.
I couldn't see her face.
Literally.
They had to give her a bag.
We had to go get a bag for her.
Yeah.
They got a really big bag for me.
They really did.
I kept forgetting my phone too because I had so much merch.
So I put my phone on the side and then like I would go get
out of the store and like meet up with them.
And I was like my phone and I'd come back and then and I
came out with more merch.
And I was like, I got more merch, guys.
And I was like, my phone!
And then I go back in.
Crap.
I'm in comedy of ours over here.
But I didn't show my chat the drinks.
I mean, um.
Jen's in my chat.
And she said that it looks like your plushies are on a date.
I have a photo where we hold hands.
I took a photo where they hold hands.
They're in the drink in the middle.
It's the lady in the tramp.
So you guys see at the, in the tea, one.
There's the logo and then because they would do a
presentation of the drink.
And then I think I wrote I wrote this down when they was
like describing the fake drink because I thought it was so
funny.
Let me see what I wrote.
Um, okay, the bartender came in and was like, first you must
worship this drink because he's like a god amongst god.
And he's like, so he's a winner.
I thought it was so funny it's like you must worship it and
yeah so they create a logo too and it's like pomegranate and
brandy i know mine was a fruity drink it had like orange
juice and um i know he had orange juice in it and then um uh
iron mouse was also pomegranate and then i'm trying to
remember what rin was let me look at the picture because
don't you're pure ethanol baby
What it was.
Oh, wait, no.
Rin was pomegranate.
And then Iron Mouse was...
And yours was your cherry or something.
Oh, that seems fitting.
Yeah.
Oh, it was so cute.
It's raspberry.
There's a raspberry in it.
Because, like, the cry for my song was, I think, it's, like,
viral in Korea, too.
Because the moment your song was playing, people were
turning around, like, talking about...
about your music video like yeah I was like oh you're like
wait they were like oh and they were doing the cry for me
like pose because they're like that's where the song comes
from because I know it went fire on TikTok I think they were
like realized like that's where the song came from and I saw
like these international celebrities no but saying is it was
like a group of teenagers like Korean guys and they were
doing the cry for me pose and they were pointing at the
video and I They go Did they did they say yadu?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't say it came a word now Yadu and then fake it walked
right through the door and then everyone walked through.
I'm still so sad.
No, the thing is after we left for the tour Like apparently
the league team came back came to the facility two hours
later.
I was just I swear they're like you guys can't come in yet.
Don't come in I was like, I would have camped out.
I would have stayed there until you showed up.
And you considered, Toki, that at a certain point, you might
be the problem.
No, it can't be me.
That's the kids all wrong.
Yeah, it can't be me.
But that was basically it.
That was the bar experience.
It was really cool, though, because it's like, you know,
it's literally like you literally give them like the name,
character description, how much alcohol you want.
the person like yeah the personality and stuff like that and
then they just make it and they just base it off of that so
cute yeah it was really cute there was a lot of drinks but
it was really cute look I'll have to go back if heaven
forbid they decide to have us back a second time after so
cute what I just I'm trying to like think of what other
stuff we did I want to There's just not a bunch we can talk
about that's not under NDA.
Yeah, not under NDA.
Yeah, yeah.
I will say, we went shopping one day and I sent this photo
to Mouse and it was, there was a cinnamon roll cafe.
Oh, yes.
Did I throw it?
It was a, it was a, it was a whole story, the store, that
entire, and then there was a cafe in the back.
So like on the left there, that entire little area is, it
was all cinnamon roll stuff.
I didn't go in there because I knew I was going to spend a
million dollars and I had already spent a million dollars at
all of Young.
I was like, I'm glad I wasn't there.
I don't know what damage was done.
So I bought a little clothes for my little plushie and for
faker too So it was funny because like there was a store
right next to the Bar that was selling like little dog
clothes too for like the little plushies and then I bought a
made I bought a made outfit for faker.
I haven't put For the for the plushie not for actual faker
Yeah, the plushie that was like I could possibly have told
if you haven't clarified I'm dressing up bigger.
I think I gotta specify.
It's so...
No, but the cafe I noticed because I was like, oh, because I
went to the one in Japan.
It's literally the same one in Japan, the Cinemorial Cafe,
but the food is the same because I had the food there.
So they just took that to Korea as well.
But it was really cute though.
It was really, really cute.
was, I think I messaged Mouse.
And I was like, sometimes it's good that you're not here
because you wouldn't have bought the whole store.
Oh, no, but the staff bought the whole store.
Yeah, the staff bought some stuff for you.
It was really cute.
They didn't tell you.
Yeah, they bought like a bunch of stuff there.
Secrets.
They were there were surprises.
We're sharing their surprise.
Surprise.
You're getting stuff.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I saw some of the team members because me and Jen were
like, we should go get clean for Mouse.
And then we saw a team they're definitely buying something
from us we're good i think the stuff the staff got all of us
like a lot of stuff to the point where i believe before we
even arrived some of them had to be told like no you can't
buy them that they're not gonna have room in like in their
suitcases when they leave oh oh my god they pay for like
really generous they they pay for so many things like our
food and everything i i had to go to the salon because i was
like it's korea i gotta go to Also, because, like, I haven't
gotten out in a while, so I had, like, lots of gray hair and
everything.
I didn't have time to do it before the trip.
And then, the staff paid for it all, too.
I was not expecting that.
They literally paid for my entire salon trip and everything.
And you know what I'm still upset about?
We never got our spa day, and I'm still sorry.
Oh, yeah, you guys never know.
We just didn't have a spa treatment, and we just didn't have
time.
We didn't have time, and the only time that we really had to
go was, like, before dinner one day.
and a facial, you walk out of that like a little hop, like a
little oily little hop goblin.
And we didn't have time to go back to like the hotel to like
change and shower.
Yeah, they were like, you're going straight to dinner after
that.
It was like a full 12 hour day.
And I was like, I don't wanna put on like my old clothes and
then walk in with my hair like slicked, greased back.
Cause that was the night we went to like, I think that like
one of the nice dinners.
Yeah.
And I was like, I'm gonna be a little, hi man, maybe you're
having me.
Like, nice to meet you.
I'm like, drip, like I might like, in my hair like my face
is like shiny and like the the sponge bob meme where he's
like like shiny and round like i was like i don't want to do
that i yes yes they never got through spy day at all during
that time our schedule was so fully booked every day it was
like yeah i i saw the schedule and there was so much stuff
on it like oh my gosh no also it sucks because like mousy
was there for half of it but it was half of that was NDA it
was yeah yeah all the stuff we can't talk to I know maybe
this time next year I know I told chat like one day I'll be
able to tell you about my blood sweat and tears mostly sweat
actually a lot of sweat we can't we'll disappear tomorrow if
we say anything it's okay if if my if the government asks it
was a work trip there for everything i paid for was a
business expense that's true some photos in the chat of
things that we can talk about we can talk about like the
dinners and like the meats oh my god yeah that was crazy oh
my god yeah it was like we can talk about that we can talk
about we can talk about this we can talk about the clamp
exhibit that me and doki went oh yeah we went to a clamp
exhibit it was so pretty yeah i will send a bunch of photos
so that you can live what we lived Yeah, live by Kirsten.
Yeah, so here it is, chat.
It was like a briefcase of me, basically.
Yeah.
Like he opened it and there was smoke coming out.
Which I presume was intentional.
Oh, here's the, here's the paper signature that we, that we
stared up at.
Um, I want to see what else we can talk about.
It was, the food was amazing.
The silence is definitely.
Yeah, I'm like looking through my food.
The food was so good.
Oh my god.
we finally were able to eat like the donkatsu because like
that was something we won't um like i really wanted to eat
uh but this was like the girl you guys were already gone so
like they're like what do you want to eat doki and i was
like donkatsu and so um it was crazy because like the staff
ordered i didn't even realize i was saying it was like
bulldog donkatsu so it was like james bond that i did sorry
yeah i was that for some reason i did it mostly for myself
so i could so so i There's Sad Doggo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You didn't even buy Sad Doggo.
I did.
You didn't even roll for him.
I felt bad because we couldn't use our credit cards on the
gotcha machines.
You could only use a Korean.
Yeah, you could only use a Korean credit card and I felt bad
asking for them to pay for my gambling.
So I only did one and then turned to Doki going, I want to
do this one and this one.
I did too!
You can't say that!
That was one more than you!
Fowl!
I can't even put what we wanted out of the gotcha though,
didn't we?
Because I got a little copy thing.
Wait, so this is a sad dog gotcha machine and then this is a
pooping dog gotcha?
Yeah, I got... There were some wholesome ones.
But these were the chaotic ones.
Yeah, it was like, which sad doggo are you?
Yeah, I got the far right, the one where he's like lying
down and crying.
That's the one I get.
I really wanted the medicine cone one.
I'm going to have so many inexplicable photos on my PC.
Yeah, you didn't even get sad doggo.
Oh, no.
I did the otter one.
I actually got the super rare pull for the otter.
Oh, yeah.
He was inside like a little shell.
It was great.
Yeah, one of the girls was like, oh my God, wait, you got
the super rare.
And I was like, yeah, I did.
Yeah, I got the super rare.
I'm looking like through my photo.
Actually, I wrote notes down.
Half the notes I can't even say until...
I know.
I was going through my photos and I was like, can't share
that we that entire part two catch-up stream in six months
we might even be allowed to talk about that stuff yeah it's
a little mystery but you'll have to wait too long that's all
we can say it won't be like a 20-year thing it will be but
it's also not next week so maybe don't hold your breath
within this year i'll just in this financial year it'll be
it'll be at some point i'm sure in this year you'll find out
what it is but we'll you'll see all of us do more stuff
together because we we did talk about how we want to do
another like doing a gaming collab in the future too so you
will see us do a bunch of stuff leading up to where the fuck
we were doing in Korea like foreshadowing yeah we guys will
see it and go oh oh my god it was so fun you know how okay
cuz like since I was the first one to tweet about it because
like they're like you know Doki you could tweet about you
one while I was still in Korea like so you know how my first
tweet was the t1 thing so yeah because of course it was yeah
so everyone was like why did t1 flew them to korea i feel
like we're allowed to say that wasn't it necessarily because
otherwise i would have been allowed to meet faker yeah yeah
i would be allowed to be faker if t1 did fly us out i would
if only yes everyone was like why what's why it's so
herrings so because it was like me i'm lee rin and iron
mouse and why are all four of us at the t1 facility but it
was just my thing i just asked for a tour of the facility
that was a dokey special yeah i was like i'll go along you
know they asked me and i was like yeah i want to go i i am
interested to hear and like we can't confirm or deny uh
mostly because we think it's funny to watch you guys
floundering but i would love to hear what people actually
think we were doing so that later we can laugh at you for
being wrong.
Oh, that's a good idea.
What do you guys think we were doing?
Yeah, chat.
What do you think we were doing?
What?
Go ahead.
I'm going to make it so easily.
A backflip.
Okay, close enough.
I saw people, some people thought that like, we were going
to sing the next League like League song.
Just the one that League of Legends 2.
Yes.
We're like, we're going to be the new KDA that's the B tier.
What a line-off!
Dang!
Forming Avengers Korea.
I asked these four non-Korean people.
The villains and K-pop demon hunters too.
Oh my god!
My dream!
Let us in John Netflix!
Let us in!
Yeah, because it is...
It is a because because like if it was T1 related, it is a
weird lineup.
I will say Yeah, I have no idea any of these don't you have
to explain like just how serious this esports shit was Yeah,
we went you're like T1 building.
Yeah, you're like oh my goodness We're like what's T what
who's faker?
What's a what's a faker?
Why is he named that?
Best esport in the faker or in the fucking world.
So I was like excuse me Doki brings out like a TED talk,
like a PowerPoint presentation.
So this is Faker, the best league player in the world, and
this is Team One, the best esport org in the world.
I can see it in my mind.
And we are going there, guys.
Yeah, this was the briefing she gave us before we set out
for the hotel that morning.
Yeah, yeah, and I was like, Faker has a tower that he, just
for him.
Apparently he like rents it out to like the other teams and
stuff.
So he has a second tower where he plays for he actually
stays in.
Wait, so he owns the tower.
Yeah, he's so good.
two towers yeah that's how crazy how come t1 says you're
allowed two towers well you see rand if you start winning
all the championships in the world you too can get your own
tower dokey's dokey tower will say to sarah these days oh my
oh i just remember yeah i was saying earlier like our
schedule was so fully booked we're literally there morning
till night um and like we could rarely go back to your
hotels like maybe like there was a time yeah i i like bought
a switch too for like this trip and i was like i'll get to
play my pocopia game literally we got back into the hotel
and i face planted into my bed i was like oh my we like we
just passed out right after and then the worst part because
they just announced it i had to be earlier than everyone
else to go to to yeah so if you guys didn't know i was
street fighter tournament next week it was just announced
today so but i had to practice it because um i'm gonna get
my ass fucking kicked she wants to get her tower so she's
got to practice yeah so i crave real estate 7 a.m almost
every day to at first they took me to a pc bang um and then
but then the pc bang did not have street fighter installed
they had techin that techin that t-o-x-o that every other
fighting game but street fighter was not popular in korea so
i was so confused i was just like so because they were like
oh it'll take 15 minutes to download i was there for two
almost two hours and i only had 10 downloaded i was like oh
what jesus i was like i guess i can't guys i mean can i use
so i had to use the studios pc the one where we did the off
collab to like to like download nothing else yeah nothing
else I know I felt so bad about being like I'm so tired and
then Doki would be like yeah you're tired I was here for two
hours already must be nice like first time like literally
yeah so yeah so I was just locked up in the fucking PC room
like just like right after our off collab ended I downloaded
Street Fighter for the next day literally like we won't out
of the room and she was just like okay it's time to go into
steam yeah you guys just saw me closing all the apps i was
like downloading street fighter and then they was literally
trapped oh my god i was trapped there from morning till
night just well all of us were trapped there yeah oh man one
way or the other yes but it was fun it was so fun i would i
wish we could share the stories where mousy was there but we
would like like with a double or something a body double
yeah no youtube is i can do that oh yeah i wish you were
there like even just to taste the food oh yeah i wish i
could have just like teleported through all phone screens
yeah exactly yeah wait i want to show chat did you see these
did you see these these meats the meats in the box oh yeah i
showed the the the big but pretty one the really big one the
really big one yeah there were like there was like we went
to this one place we went to this one place and they had
like meats on display in like these boxes it was incredible
and then my favorite was they brought us a box of meat and
when it opened like dry ice like steam came out yeah that
one oh yeah I was like oh my god it's Lord meat himself it
was amazing oh my god yeah I also was looking through my
notes do you guys remember it I wish we did anyone take the
photo of the and frog next to next to our hotel of course i
think jen did but i didn't didn't okay so like you know like
ren and i we both okay i wish i could we should have a photo
so you show irons but it's just a big frog it was a giant
frog next to our hotel but ren i noticed it on the first day
and we were like pointing it i was like look at that giant
frog but amalee's his deal amalee like three days later was
like do you guys see that giant frog and i was no it was
just me and jen Dude, I was so tired.
I didn't know where I was.
And I went, wow, look at that frog.
And there was Silas and the donkey went, we've been seeing
that frog the last three fucking days.
Yeah, I was like, we pointed that frog out the last three
days.
What do you mean you saw it now?
It was just the way you were like, we've been seeing that
frog.
Yeah, like, because we always were in the car ride back
every day.
It's not like, this is a tall frog.
giant ass frog.
It was so big.
I'm more impressed than anything that you missed it.
Oh wait, Jen says she's dropping the photo in Discord.
Okay, the crazy, the funny thing is it was surrounded by all
these tiny frogs too.
It was just one giant frog.
It was like being worshipped by all these tiny frogs.
Look at it.
Look at his lordship.
Lordship frog.
I'm trying to find him.
This is a brilliant picture because of the motion blur in
the foreground.
It's in pictures.
It always looks like she's running away from the frog whilst
trying look at that you guys see that frog we've been saying
that frog wait oops sorry wrong one yeah i'm posting in the
group chat for uh it's in it's in pictures but oh my god i
don't i don't but she's so big look at him for the last
three days a human being for scale he's giant he was a giant
frog so big look at this giant ass frog that amalie
conveniently did not see for three days I always let
disassociate you in the back seat of the car.
I was in food coma, recovering from the spice I had
consumed.
The thing, it's okay, even if you don't see the frog, the
frog sees you.
So it was like, it closed.
How could she not see it?
The thing is, we were passing by this frog day out and day,
like, night in.
We had to drive past him to get back to, like, our hotel and
stuff.
It's not easy to miss.
and yet i was just tuning you guys out like three days in a
row that's all that i was like okay here's the frog there it
is oh don't worry i was just ignoring you guys okay i had
sweat in my eyes i didn't see they were so tired to be fair
oh my god genuinely god oh my god i gotta i gotta run to the
little frogs room i'll be right back but i'm gonna leave
chat with you
uh did mousy did what was your favorite part for it when you
the things you can talk about oh my god i feel like the
things that i can talk about are so little yeah god yes
again emphasis on the work and the work yeah yeah but moment
the moment everything is revealed she can explain we'll let
her explain everything well i like the view from the top of
the tower oh it was so pretty oh yeah it was like the i have
some nice views out to be fair, yeah.
For the T1 facility, the rooftop was sponsored by Red Bull
because it gives you wings.
So I thought that was really clever.
So it was so pretty because it was just like, apparently
like all, like you can see so many things.
The beautiful side of Red Bull brings a tear to this online
zone.
At the top.
And then there was like the, what was it?
There was that, you know, the famous Korean like building on
the mountain.
I don't remember what it was called.
Just the one.
The one on the mountain.
It was like the broadcast tower or whatever.
You could see it from the very top.
It was, it was like, what Mouse was there is just that the
things she could talk of, she was there for, we can't talk
about it yet.
Not allowed.
We'll get in trouble.
Maybe we should have just stayed, like, saved this stream
for when we'd actually, like, announce the thing properly.
Yeah, the, oh yeah, the the Namsan Tower.
Yes, yeah, you could see it from the...
You could see it from the T1 building.
So it was really cool.
But it was...
It was...
It was just surreal to be there.
Like, being, like, just all over the place in Korea.
The thing is, the NDA stuff, it was surreal to do that.
No, I agree.
I won't be able to...
It's just like this is happening.
Yeah, while we say...
We'll be able to explain later.
Wow.
But but this year you'll find out this year.
It's not gonna be a 20-year thing unless something just
completely goes to shit In which case like not and then we
were all just on holiday at the same time coincidentally
don't worry about us Yeah, and then and then it's like and
then it's like we never speak about this thing project ever
again It just got shelved and then we're like someone's
asking like so how did you guys meet and we just look at him
like Hmm.
Oh, we just all happened to be in Korea at the same time.
Yeah, at the same place we all like what a coincidence
seeing you guys here yeah i saw like the the an ipad with
iron mouse's video on and i went over it's like is that iron
mouse like in the middle of korea i was just like oh my god
i can't believe we read it to each other i know and then
like i heard you two speaking i was like wait a second i
recognize those voices is that iron mouse on the ipad and
she came over yeah and then we saw amelie like towering
above everybody and we're like Hey, there's Amelie.
And then we saw Jennifer Roberts.
Yeah, with Amelie.
I like how we always use Jen's full name, like she's in
trouble.
She's Jennifer.
She's Jennifer Roberts, the Jennifer Roberts.
Oh, of course.
Sorry, my mistake.
It doesn't hit as hard, you know, Jennifer, but it's like
the Jennifer Roberts.
Chat is like fake or stalker club meeting.
All right, so apparently his schedule is that tomorrow he's
going to the beers we gotta we gotta be down the street at
that coffee shop tomorrow okay i'm going back on the plane
oh no i have to go back should have put my arm you're just
gonna be living in all of young not gonna lie you're gonna i
the only thing i dread about the possibility of going back
is just the flight i was asking like 14 hours for me that's
asking i was like why don't you just make a bunker filled
with like like no me and jen me and jen found the hacks for
the flight though we asked the the person that checked us in
at the airport if there were any rows in the back of the
plane that had nobody in them and so we booked those so we
actually had full rows to ourselves so we could go down well
you guys flights also weirdly quiet because both ways like
the way that i had the entire road to myself i didn't even
have to ask yeah silent we did we we didn't move to the back
just so we would not have the chance of having someone with
us but yeah i got to lay down the whole flight and sleep it
was great i got business class It's not like, but it's not
that they pay for my business class.
It's like, yeah, they're like, all right, Jokey gets
business class and we'll put the rest in God.
It was not that.
I asked if I could pay, like upgraded myself.
So I don't, but the thing is, they still haven't billed me
for it.
So essentially they did pay for my, oh, congratulations.
You got away with it.
Yeah.
And I got away with it.
Wasted the budget on Doki's business class.
Now all you gotta do is fake your death and you're resorted.
I could pay for it, but I thought they were like, oh, we
paid it for you and we're gonna bill you later.
But then I never got sent the bill.
I don't know.
Oh, free business class.
Let's go.
Well, why would you say it in public?
Now you're gonna send me the bill the next day.
They're gonna be like 8 a.m.
Korean time.
They're up.
Yeah.
No, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure they'll rewatch this VOD just to make sure
we don't need just to make sure like let's go they're not
said too much yeah no they're gonna say hey guys how you
doing nice seeing you last week they're gonna add us on the
server right now they're gonna add us on the server and be
like um at this timestamp you guys mentioned everyone stop
everyone stop streaming
No, no, we're professional.
We're professional.
We're so professional.
Also, we have so much fun.
We have so many stories that aren't related.
Yeah, like...
Because we did so much...
I can't wait to tell you guys about the time.
Like, that was so cool.
I love that.
Oh my God.
And then when, you know, when...
Okay, I don't have a beeper.
Can you beep for me?
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
So when we beep, yeah.
Wait, I have one, two.
I have to just open my program.
You're down, boy.
Here, wait, I got you.
I got you.
I'm gone.
I want your fucking language.
I want to watch your fucking language.
Going up.
She's going up.
They're leaking.
They're leaking, guys.
Send it.
I really love it.
When Doki goes.
Faker, faker!
Faker!
What?
We're faker!
Yeah, the project's off.
They're gonna launch this and they're gonna be like, God, we
can't, these people are so unprofessional.
We can't walk with them anymore.
We can't, yeah, we can't, they're like, sorry, and then they
rip the NDA.
They're gonna fly us back, force us to give all of our,
like, gifts and presents and T1 merch back and fly us back
home again.
No!
We brought this on ourselves.
merch no oh my t1 merch that's the only reason you came as
far as we can tell that was my career into my schedule that
was my highlight also you know what i'm sold it's also
literally the only thing we could sort of talk about too so
god yeah the way that it is oh my god i forgot so it's crazy
the most stuff i was able to do was literally the day you
guys left because there was no more work stuff so i thought
it was funny they just took he just took me everywhere and
then so one of them they took me to like this little village
like this like old korean um village um like like like how
was it called like the like you know like back then lunch
time did you have between our flies and you guys left in the
morning i left at night so they must be nice yeah so like a
historical village And it was so funny because there was a,
you know how like the FIFA World Cup is coming soon, right?
So, yeah, so like soccer is really popular in Korea.
So it was so funny because the historical village was doing
a World Cup collab with like Nike and stuff.
And a bit of a choice.
Yes, it was so funny because there was like, and you look
into like the little rooms, there was a Nike look.
on like some of the labs.
I was like, that's so...
Wait, let me show you guys what timeline is this?
I was just like one.
That's like...
I guess like, I can't believe Nike was around like 500 years
ago, guys.
Oh, God.
Historical artifact.
It's historical art.
It was.
Let me show you guys the photo.
It was so funny.
I took a photo.
Do you guys see it?
Look.
Wait, I gotta see this.
Oh, that's funny.
just like wait what can i show this yeah you can show this
it was the night like on the ancient odd of air jordans oh
my god anthropologists are gonna be studying this for years
the old air jordans i'm showing so funny i was like why is
there a nike logo on this like and it's everywhere too you
would look into the room and wherever you see and i like the
there's a tapestry of a soccer ball too um that's at the
tomah that's like which they had back in those days in a
real i'm just gonna look up when did they invent football if
football's been around for a long time i don't think well i
don't think that specific ball was around that that's when
was the nike logo invented 1971 oh the family heirloom but i
think literally 500 years ago yeah same thing the nike
labels are out either so but the thing is i don't know if i
took let me see i took pictures of it so like there's like
the courtyard and everything too so the courtyard um they
put all these like stalls and everything of like sport sport
merch and then like um and then it's so funny because like
the staff was like oh look they have this they have this
traditional stuff i was like look there's the traditional
bikinis because they were selling they were selling like
nike bikinis at one of the stalls and i was like only the
highest level of historical accuracy out here i was just
like i don't think they're all the ladies back in the day
back in the day i don't know oh i didn't take it
unfortunately i didn't take the photo of the stalls it was
literally just like the courtyard was just all like these
like little boosts and stuff and everything.
And I was just like, this feels a little jarring, like next
to these old villages.
Bit of a total dissonance, though.
The family treasure.
Yeah.
I love the Nike lantern.
That was like, that is so, it was like everywhere too.
Like you would look in and then you see the Nike lantern.
And I was like, and I like how they like aged the lantern as
if like it was always there type of.
in my chat they just said ama is younger than the nike logo
what the what do i mean few how do i time this person out
purge wait what does this mean why does it say unpassed why
does that say i can either purge or delete wait what the
fuck you purge them from the existence they just never
existed bye you know what you did oh purge deletes all their
messages oh yeah like you literally existence no i am
inevitable you cannot snap them oh god let me see oh yeah oh
i never showed the pokemon photos to my chat let me show
that to them oh yeah how you put those oh there's me holding
hands holding faker's hand oh i don't want to comment on
that oh can i show them can i show these yeah you can show
these this i'm so jealous that you absorbing his winning
aura like you know like as a like a parasite like a parasite
i just love that your your little plushies look like they
belong like in the same world they're in the same world
that's adorable yeah i'm just i'm sure if he doesn't win
worlds this year i'm sorry i it's not my fault Good.
It's on him at that point.
Guys, you don't understand, I really need to win my Street
Fighter tournament next week.
You sucked away his winning air.
No!
Oh, God, it's really because you touched the chair, isn't
it?
To be fair, the chair is the real taker.
The man is just a puppet.
I did also touch the chair.
Maybe it'll be the scuff.
Oh, he has the moon.
So it's, like, absorbing his power, like, space jam.
That's...
breathe it all in yeah i'm i'm gonna space jam him i'm
that's a threat if i have a hard one oh god all right oh
yeah here's the let me show them a picture of the the
pokemon park let's see also i did not have you guys unpacked
it i did not unpack at all i've started but it's not going
well it it's not i to be fair my chat always like you never
unpack and that is so true every trip i leave in my luggage
until the next trip and i just yeah i just dump everything
out of the suitcase and then just pack it and bring it to
the next work trip i oh god so yeah see i'm looking through
my photos see if there's anything in here genuinely like
even some of the better photos that we took will have been
under nda because of the place we took them in right like
damn it this is so photogenic i wish i could tell anyone no
that's why i was taking so many photos that like outside
like of like stuff we were just like walking around and
doing i was like then we can share yeah but but we can share
it in the the next the not the obviously not the next stream
but like on that on that stream when it's happened when it
happens exactly oh my god i got a photo of this truffle um
meat and it was so delicious.
You really liked your truffle, didn't you?
Oh my god.
They have so much truffle stuff in Korea and it was so
delicious.
Oh my god.
My mouth is watering thinking about it.
It was like so salty and flavorful.
Oh my god.
And then also it's truffle stuff and then blue cheese stuff.
They love blue cheese.
To be fair, I wasn't a huge fan of the blue cheese It's a
quiet taste.
Yeah.
The blue cheese meat.
Did you guys try the blue cheese meat?
I tried it.
It was like all right, but I wasn't a huge fan of it.
I think I tried one and I was like, I'm done now.
That's enough.
I put one in my mouth because like the woman who was like
helping us like like cook the meat was like, try this.
And she like put it on my plate.
She was like, eat this.
And I was like, okay.
And so I put it in my mouth and I chewed once and I like
held it.
I was like, ah.
Yeah.
Cause you don't want to be rude because you know, they're
watching you too.
Like feet.
It was like feet.
It was like a foot was in my...
I was like, uh, like dirty, like gym socks were in my mouth.
Oh, no.
I was like, and people were talking to me, and I was like,
just holding it in my mouth like a dog that has like an
animal in my mouth that I'm not supposed to have.
I was like, maybe they'll, if they all look away, and I
like, I had to spit it out in my napkin.
I was like, I can't.
Like, I was trying to force myself to eat it.
My eyes were watering.
But I felt so bad.
You tried, and that's what counts.
You were willing to experiment outside your comfort zone.
It wasn't a great, it wasn't a success.
And that makes you braver than me, which is pretty easy.
Like bring back the trouble.
Oh my God.
I was looking through photos.
There was a five guys.
We found a five guys in Korea.
It was so interesting seeing what had made it like across
from, you know, the US and the UK.
I was like, that's a five guys in my town.
Well, what's he doing in Korea?
He shouldn't be there.
And also a Tim Hortons.
Tim Hortons that they just called Tims.
Just called Tim.
And they have like the, they have like the Canada, like the
Canada logo.
Yeah, yeah, they're like, you could, they got to be, make
everyone know, like this is a Canadian brand.
Like, they're like, here's Maple Leaf, behind Tim's.
Yeah, it was like, it's just called Tim's.
And I was like, where's Horton?
What happened?
You got divorced?
Like, yeah, then you got divorced.
Like the wife took Horton's.
Like, they're on a first name basis with Tim.
Oh, that's what it is.
But he's Canadian.
You know, where's our food?
Like stuff like McDonald's or Starbucks or whatever.
It's like, well, that's everywhere in the world at this
point.
You can't escape them.
That makes sense.
Why is Outback Steakhouse here?
Oh, so five guys.
I don't even have a five guys in Canada.
Like, what?
We should have gone.
I don't even have a five guys.
We should have just gone there.
Yeah.
It was wild.
I took a picture of the five guys restaurant.
It was like, I was like, I don't even get this in Canada.
It's all the way here.
is my luxury yeah i've always wanted i should have tried the
five guys there i've actually really want i've always wanted
to try five guys if we ever get invited back heaven forbid
so let's all go to five orders to see if it was any
different because i love i love american five guys um but i
really wanted them they add truffles the difference would be
i'm sure their bread because a lot of the korean bread is a
lot sweeter so i'm sure the bun would be much sweeter um but
yeah that's That's like the only difference I can really see
is like maybe like their potatoes are different and like
their bread is different like for the bun but The rest is
just meat and cheese baby That's that's how we that's that's
the American way, you know, so true Yeah, maybe their oil is
different, but okay to be fair all of like like our fast
food restaurants at in Korea look so fancy like it Yeah, it
looks so fancy and a lot cleaner A lot cleaner the The
standard seems to be higher over there.
The standard.
They don't just eat garbage like us.
No, it's like, it's like Wendy's in Japan.
You know how like Wendy's in Japan is like a family
restaurant that like, but with just like, it's like an
actual like dining place.
Oh my god, you guys actually tried.
Holy shit.
So it's, yes, it's like, I remember when I first came to
Japan, well not first came to Japan, but one of my first
work trips in Japan, the staff was like, we should, we
should go to Wendy's.
And I was just like, maybe not, you know, because I didn't
know which way.
I was like, yeah, guys, I don't think I want my first day on
my work trip to be at Wendy's.
But like, no, no, you don't understand.
This is like a dining place.
It was good, though.
It was actually really decent.
I was like, I don't have to go next time around.
Yeah, you should go to Wendy's in Japan.
It's actually pretty good.
Yeah.
I think they only just started getting Wendy's in the UK as
well.
Or like only in the last few years.
So maybe I like compare and contrast.
And they're not viciously disappointed by the UK version, as
I always do.
I think it's kind of like how KFC is like a treat for like,
like on Christmas for like...
Yeah, yeah, because like one advertiser lied about like, you
know, the story behind it.
No, actually.
They were like, we got to promote KFC in Japan.
How do we promote this?
And then there's a... I think it was like this American like
marketing guy was like, we'll lie.
and saying in america they basically they they did this like
ad in japan where they're like in america we eat kfc for
christmas it's tradition it's the american way i mean i
would believe that and then so like people believed it
because it was like everywhere in japan and then people
believe they're like we got oh my god we should try and do
this too like let's let's let's try this american tradition
no guys stop no guys and then it turned into a japanese
tradition now where Like, people have to reserve Christmas
buckets in advance because they can sell them months in
advance.
Yeah, months in advance for Christmas in Japan.
Honestly, American marketing is kind of just lying,
honestly.
It's like, we're like, we're going to lie and tell them
that's what we do in America.
And it worked.
It's now a Japanese tradition.
Damn it, that good.
But they do.
Because it's like a special bucket, too.
It's like a special theme bucket dedicated to Christmas in
Japan.
because like Christmas would not was not was like it's like
a Western holiday so it's not celebrated in Japan so when
they were bringing like a religious holiday over there it's
more like a couples thing yes yeah it's a couples thing so
when they bring when they brought Christmas over to Japan
and they're like yeah Americans eat KFC during that time
because like they never celebrated Christmas before so
they're like really I'll do that too and then it's like
things you couldn't have known could you like really oh my
god I want to try this tradition like but again Again, it's
America.
I wouldn't believe that if you told me.
That makes perfect sense.
Yeah, you're like, you can also celebrate traditional
American Christmas.
Yeah!
So that's basically it.
That's how KFC became so popular in Japan.
But yeah, it's like...
Just by lying.
Yep, just...
Yep, by lying.
So remember, kids, if you ever feel down about your lack of
ability, don't worry.
So do the execs at KFC.
yeah it worked though honestly it worked out for him the u.s
when they intentionally spread misinformation for fun and
for profit i wonder if they just make their entire year's
like goal of funds in one day oh you mean i mean i'd hope
not maybe that doesn't seem like a particularly good way to
run a business it doesn't but i think i'm not j i'm not john
kfc but you He's just John Vtuber.
I'm only allowed one job title.
Not yet.
That's a good attitude.
You'll go far with that mentality in life.
Exactly.
I just...
Sorry, that just reminded me completely unrelated, but when
we got back to the airport in London, we were going up to
like the car park and we were in the elevator and there was
like a baby in a stroller who was just like staring at me.
And he kind of put his hand out.
a little high five and i was like you're gonna go far in
life with that with that mentality kid and just walked away
that's cute cute that's cute oh my god i hope that stays
with him for his formative years i hope it scares him at
night britain is so brit is so good at social interactions
like even with the language barrier remember when you were
talking to this this korean staff like and you're just
talking to the translator too and it was so cute like i'm
and leah and i we did meet like one person who uh who also
spoke japanese no english oh that was so funny that is so
funny and i was like it's time to lock the ever-loving hell
in that was beautiful yeah because like while you guys were
talk trying to talk to each other with the translator like
app i'm lean i would get wasted like across the table two
different kinds of people you know it's the duality man like
we were one of the staff members she was a baddie she was
she was a baddie else if you say so and and she was like
making us drinks and stuff for amalie and i and we're gonna
fucking waste it off of those drinks well she was like she
was like batty what's that and i was like i get to teach you
something new i was like i was like a good thing i was like
oh yeah you want to be a batty i was like a batty is like
hot hot lady like oh she a batty yeah she was a batty no but
she was like making us like what was it it was like beer and
soju she was beer and The way she was mixing it, I'm not
sure if you noticed, one of the waiters, like waitresses
came over, and she was like mixing the drink, like their
spoon, and the waitress like nodded in approval.
She was like, yeah, she knows what she was doing.
Yeah, she was like, ooh.
She kept giving us more.
She was like, do you want more?
And then like, cause like the first drink, you have to chug
it.
So we were like, and it was beer and soju.
So I didn't out-drink you.
I out-drinked Doki.
I was so proud of myself.
I don't think that's something to be proud of.
I have very low tolerance.
I drank so much you can go with the tolerance for drinking.
But I'm not the lowest.
That's all that matters.
I drank two.
She drank three cups.
You're dangerous, bro.
I drank two, two cups.
You're danger to yourself.
And then Rin and the other Korean staff were having a
wholesome conversation from across the table.
I would just chill.
I look up and it's just like, oh, yeah.
Oh, this can't end.
Wow.
Yeah, we were not, we're not sober.
Like, I'm really not sober.
This might be my circus, but those sure as hell aren't my
monkeys.
Anyway, back to it.
Actually, I did not know that Rin spoke Japanese, so like,
like, the one girl was trying- I'm at a very basic level,
but like, you know what?
It was enough.
No.
It was actually incredible, because the one girl was trying
to speak English to us, and we were trying to like speak
like English to her, and it wasn't working, and then one of
the other staff was like, Oh, yeah, she only speaks like
Korean and Japanese, and then you like- And my ears pumped
up, and I'm like, Japanese, and then you spoke the longest
string of Japanese so fast and I was like, oh, I like turned
to you slowly.
I was like, holy shit.
I was like, I don't know.
I said, just to keep the illusion alive, you know?
It was amazing.
I'll pass the N5 one of these days.
Yeah, that's pretty, that's pretty crazy.
Like a sleeper agent you woke up.
It was crazy.
Um, Sumi Mosen, Nihongo woe shabari mascar.
Like, oh my God, he's flowing.
No, you were really good.
Thank God someone thinks so.
More fluent than us, for sure.
More fluent than us.
Yeah.
Yeah, but it was really cute though, because we were like,
she wanted to learn more English, so she was trying really
hard to talk to us in English too.
So it was really, really cute.
Yeah.
You were talking a lot about anime.
We didn't know what to talk about at first, and so there was
just moments of silence, and then Doki, it was so cute.
You went, your favorite anime?
And I just say things in motion.
That's the first thing I could think of.
I was just like, what's your favorite anime?
Like, I'm just like, I'm proud to be relatable with the
kids.
Yeah, we really didn't know what to talk about first.
We were like, uh, how's the weather?
As someone that doesn't really watch anime.
I was like, what's your favorite anime, guys?
You've seen those cartoons on the television, kid.
It's just funny because we had to also like Google how you
say Korean Pokemon because we were talking about like our
favorite.
Oh, of course.
They've all different like more boys names for every every
line.
Yeah, yeah, they had like We were asking the staff and
stuff.
Yeah, they had different names and everything.
So we had to like Google the pictures and show them the
picture and they'll be like, oh, is that?
I remember like- Holy shit, it's Pikachu!
But like, it's similar to Japanese because Charizard was
Lizard Dawn.
And it was similar in Korean, but I don't- I think it was
pronounced similar too.
So I was like, oh, Lizard Dawn.
I was like, I know that.
I was like- Yeah.
My favorite was Bulbasaur.
We were like, oh, Bulbasaur.
And they were like, who?
And then we showed them a photo and everyone, like, erupted
into like oh yeah oh that's so-and-so i love that little
dude there's the most popular pokemon in korea we found that
out they're like she's so popular and we're like oh a bad
choice i guess yeah yeah bulbosaur is known as oh isang
haisi you just googled that yeah it translates to strange
seed oh yeah and then we were explaining why i say we were
explaining how bulbosaur like why Bulbasaur was called
Bulbasaur and we're like Dinosaur.
He's a bulb.
Yeah, Dinosaur.
Yeah, they're like, oh!
Honestly, so clever of the people who adapted like it into
English.
Like, so clever.
And they're going to do like a thousand of those.
Like, Massey, what's your favorite Pokemon?
I don't have a lot of patience.
Massey.
Because, like, we were talking about our favorite Pokemon
during the day.
What was your favorite?
What's your favorite Pokemon?
Oh, that's a classic.
Well, I'm like the duality of man because I like Gengar and
I like Sylveon, but I also like tankathon a lot so oh oh
it's like your color choices yeah yeah it's like it's like
your color and then gangar I think it's also your favorite
yeah it's my favorite um but it was only for the wrong
reasons though because like I thought it was super hardcore
because I read this like little text because you know how
she has ribbons and stuff on her design but it's like part
of her technically flesh ribbons like it's like made of skin
so i was like that's hardcore like she's touching you with
her fleshy ribbons i was like fleshy ribbons because that's
your hands are made off she's gonna freak yeah because like
that's that's like sylvia's whole thing is where she's like
so empathetic with her and she likes to touch you with her
ribbons to know what you're feeling and i'm like that's made
of flesh i was like it's not a ribbon it's literally i mean
what made off to be fair.
Wait, I'm curious, chat, what Pokemon reminds you of each of
us?
Like, when you look at us, like what Pokemon would you pair
us with?
Like, based off of our, like, designs.
Our personality.
Personality, but mostly designs.
Don't you dare say that Pastor Chazard?
Oh, like, has this Pinkathon for me.
I think Pinkathon makes sense for you.
Pinkathon.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
We also will be on Tinketan.
That was the same dinner where we introduced Brainrot to the
staff when we're talking about Pokemon.
Okay.
So that was some highs and some lows that evening.
We can see.
But the thing is, we were asking them if they knew Reggie
Rock because we were making Oh God.
We were going over the sounds.
Yeah.
We were like, what sound does he make?
We showed them.
We're in this Korean restaurant, very small by the way.
And me and Doki are both going, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, like reggie like three cocktails in
they're like what yeah no but they joined in everything
seems fine now they joined in on the oonsta one yeah they
showed them the video of like the reggies and they were like
what the fuck is to be fair to be fair i'm and lee and i
were not sober at that no i had i was i was two pictures in
of that really crazy stuff over at all because like
absolutely sloshed yeah like yeah and Rin wasn't there
because she's self-destructed halfway through the trip I was
clinically dead it's true yeah yeah we were like is she okay
we were so worried what Pokemon has what Pokemon can't
handle spice because maybe maybe that's Rin probably one of
the the Galarian ones the English ones oh that's true any of
the side duck which is very funny that's me that's me i'm
very i can see that too yeah yeah so cute i'm literally
wearing like a a dragon hoodie right now oh what what about
i feel like amily would be a butterfree yeah chat said frost
frost frost last frost last yes i forgot frost last i'm
thinking frost last except it's a frost last with like a
real bad attitude they said frozen Frostmoth or Frostmoth,
whatever this is.
Frostmoth is, I think, isn't that the one that evolves from
Snom?
Yeah, it is.
Yes, yes.
Snom kind of looks like my...
They can never make me hate him.
My mascots.
Maybe that kind of works out.
That's true.
What about Rind?
I'm biased.
I have a favorite Pokemon and he is kind of on brand for me,
but no one knows who he is because he's really niche.
What is it?
Oh, wait, which one?
Everyone...
My favorite Pokemon is Minior.
Minior.
Minior, the famous Pokemon that everybody knows.
How do you spell it?
Minior Pokemon?
Oh my god.
Yeah, I know, right.
What the?
Wait, which version?
Which color?
Wait, no, dude, it's not, okay, that's not as niche.
That's not that niche because the non-meteorite version is
very popular.
I've seen like that.
That's really popular in Japan, yeah.
They have lots of plushies over there because they're
like...
What kind of fooled me?
You only got plushies like last year.
What is this?
It's like...
He's from a low-level.
It's a rock candy.
So there's a lot of rock candy as merch based off of him.
And they had...
I think I own probably most of all of the Minior merch in
existence.
I have like a hand mirror.
I have like some string lights.
I have a shopping bag.
That's probably about it.
The shiny is pretty.
It's like a black with like multicolors.
You're the number one off my bum.
If Minior has 10 fans, I'm one of them.
If Minior has one fan, it's me.
If Minior has no fans, I'm no longer on this earth.
Et cetera, et cetera.
Were you the one that was telling us about the Kobo-Mon
stuff with the door mouse?
Oh my god, yeah.
So I also love I also love the mouse the mouse from Pokemon
the mice Like the one with the family you got to be most
specific a family one where mouse hold mouse hold mouse hold
Yeah, I love mass hold and in Kobo-Mon It's like the family
of mice.
It's like a dad mouse and a mom mouse and then two baby
mouse mice in makes me cry the animation is so the dad like
like clenches his chest and dies first like falls over and
one of the babies like rushes over crying and like hugs the
dad and then the mom scoops down and hugs the other one and
then they all poof yeah so basically like she becomes a
single mom mother someone animated that they're like how
should we do this it's like the dad just fucking dies like
what like god stop being dramatic just nostril fix your
right up yeah i was like we'll just put you in the pokemon
every single time yeah it was just crazy because like the
mom hugs the child's like he'll be okay and then i'm gonna
see if i can find it it's so wait i found it i found it i
found it oh dear this is the one with just the one baby oh
no it's the two here it's
I'm gonna make sure my I'm gonna make sure to get striped by
God yeah like a sandbox is striped by God and the godly
right music we can finish just like the father of the mouse
home my god what the fuck wait it's really sad
oh my god and look at the baby's like dad no And then the
mom is it?
This mouse ulcer is serious.
And then they poof.
What do they drop though?
What do they?
I don't know.
Depends on what you're like.
Well, it's written into the inheritance.
Wait, I think they drop like totems.
Wait, I think it's worth it.
Wait, what is that?
I'm trying to see.
Oh, it's berries.
Oh, I'm glad you've got your priorities in order, don't you?
my god what i need to do is it worth killing a family of a
poor is it i mean i feel like you have to make that decision
yeah it's like do i need these oh someone else decided it
for you berries that badly i'm hungry you killed them oh
here it is like not in slow motion and it's almost worse
it's almost worse how can it be worse if it's like to be
fair you're you're you're sharing a video from uh what is
that tick tock use a mouse hold lava yeah sorry sorry i feel
like there might be some bias here i like how the text says
how i how i feel seen my favorite pokemon faint so it's like
i like how there's different angles like like they've
recorded it multiple times yeah multiple angles like making
cinematic in everything so this is the 15th time you fainted
on camera today like it's okay timmy Timothy Mousehold.
Timothy Mousehold.
God love them.
I have 8,000 photos in my OBS.
Oh my God.
Let's go do like some spring cleaning.
You'll be fine.
Yeah, right?
Oh, geez.
Oh my God.
But it was a it was a very fun trip.
There's four of us.
We can reenact the Mousehold animation.
Okay, which one of us is the Mousehold father?
Which of us are like the two sickly children?
it for the team i'll die i'll not yeah i think i believe it
would be the mom i'll be the dad i think we have the talk
and then you two are the kids and then i'll take i'll take
the bullet i think we're the i think we're the tallest and
you're like no no and then the other one will run and say
i'm gonna leave like it's okay it's okay mama's here both
and then we all get sent to the hospital.
Yeah, but I get to be with Nurse Joy.
I'll be like, guys, don't worry.
I'll take it for the team.
I'll see Nurse Joy today.
That's okay.
As long as I get Officer Jenny.
We get to the Pokemon Center.
Nurse Joy is being played by Faker.
He's got the little hat on and everything.
He's got the wig on, too.
Like, the wig stays on.
I don't know.
He needs that.
I think he's fine just the way he is.
That's true.
I can't wait for my editor to have to put our wigs on
multiple different creatures, like in- God's feet.
Sorry, editor son.
I think the editor's gonna be in more pain than the actual
mouse hold.
So true.
She has to reenact everything.
Oh my gosh.
I hope for someone to animate this.
Mousy, you join us in Korea next time.
I will.
Yay.
I'll be there in real life.
Yeah, yeah.
We had- We'll take you to the Salmon Roll Cafe.
Oh my gosh.
We forgot.
We did the escape room.
I almost...
Oh, my God.
Yeah, Master's going to do an escape room for us.
But it was on the day that I was six, so you did the escape
room with my manager.
Yeah, Master's supposed to be there, too.
But we took a photo with your Mousy figure.
We beat this.
I know it's crazy to say, but we beat the escape room.
We did.
Yeah, I remember you saying when I said that I was going to
go back to the hotel, like, no, you're the smart one.
Yeah, we were...
We were very, we were scared.
We were so scared because, like, okay, this was our plan.
Amelie, we're not, we're devising a plan because I was like,
okay, Armelie's gonna be there and she's gonna be on her PC.
So, and I can Google.
Yeah, you could Google.
We're like, we're like, I got the plan.
Because it was just supposed to be us three or us four, but
like Rin checked out because, like I said, she's
self-destructive.
It wasn't feeling well, yeah.
So it was going to be me, Amelie, and Armelie's escape
route.
And I was like, okay, now that there's three of us and we
lost the biggest brain of the group we're gonna have to have
iron mouse google on her pc because that was our loophole we
honestly needed you because there was so much math there was
so much math i mean like zoe is is uh is chiming in in my
chat saying i can only describe amma and doki in the escape
room as quote shockingly competent no it was as you will no
okay so um basically they were gonna stuff the two of us in
the escape room by ourselves and we were like we wouldn't
physical component yeah yeah it was it would have been bad
it was just two of us so luckily two of our managers like
jennifer roberts and uh and zoe oh yeah yeah we came in
clutch and wait the wranglers came into rangers yeah so i'm
honestly so happy that zoe thought i was competent because i
was not doing i was not doing anything i don't know whatever
math whenever math needed to be done like mental math
because we had no calculators we couldn't bring anything i
was literally like this is heaven carry the ones it was no
they didn't let us bring like paper or pen they didn't give
us paper or pencils to write math down because there was a
lot of calculations and then i was like what you had to do
it in your head yeah i was like we could do the math for us
and i have to cancel the entire group's fingers yeah and it
wasn't just one math it was multiple math 80 of that room
was math and legitimately like my chat knows how i'm fucked
with math.
So like when everyone's doing math, I'd even pretend I just
sat down on the chair waiting for that part to be over.
Just emotionally checked out.
They were like, it's time to calculate.
And I just sat there with two chairs there.
Like that was part of the puzzle, I guess.
So I just sat there and waited until they finished the math.
Actually, there was one point in time where we were like,
the math answer was the combination locks.
And we got, we got the math wrong three times.
Like we knew, we knew we had, to calculate a and b to get c
and c was the answer but none of us could do the math and so
we tried three different times and we finally got it on the
third oh my god and then the okay the whole the whole thing
was titanic themed basically we can't say we can't say the
puzzle we can't say how to solve it yeah yeah but the it was
like titanic themed and everything it was so scary it was so
dark it was so dark and we had to do math we had to do math
we were like What do the numbers say?
Where's the light?
Where's the fucking light?
Sony says basic addition under the slightest amount of
pressure stumped everyone in the crew.
Oh yeah, we had to sign an NTA for the escape route.
I forgot about that.
I should say serious.
Yoki Yoki don't say anything.
Okay, no, I'm not telling the solution.
It's just math.
It's just, but there was that one puzzle, the last puzzle
where it was all math.
and then but it was like an item placing puzzle where the
item has the if you get the math solution correct you there
was a bunch of items and like each item has a specific
number that it's assigned to and what to do the math for it
so so there was one last item that we had to place and then
it was like i'm a lead jennifer roberts and zoe we were all
doing the math for the last one and like, I don't care.
I'm just going to put this one item here.
And then it opened.
I was just...
I literally just... That's not for me.
We all jumped.
We all jumped and screamed because it was so dark and it was
a loud noise.
Because, like, I was... They were, like, so focused.
I was like, I'm just going to put this one in.
And then it actually worked.
It was the last item.
So I just put... And then click.
And then we were out.
Well, congratulations for my... From escaping the Titanic.
Yeah, I could force it.
So one of my chats said, were y'all sinking?
like the room is slowly filling up with water as you're just
trying to do basic mental addition oh my god 45 our time was
59.99 like point like 59.59 i don't know why i went 99
but they think they gave us more time they were i think they
felt bad for us they actually added more time to our thing
yeah i think they stopped it because we were like right at
the end they're like they can do it i appreciate they added
like 15 more minutes to our room because they're like
they're so close but like on our photo it says 59.59 that we
completed oh my god yeah one more millisecond they would
have been drowned one second one more second but yeah we we
did the escape room i was i was so surprised we escaped not
gonna lie i think honestly if it was just saying that's
still in that escape room to this day we're still on titanic
yeah if it had just been me and dokey we would have used all
three hints during the first map oh no oh my god i was like
the i was like the double on the shoulder because like no
one else wanted to use the hints i was like hey guys why
don't we use the hint guys we're gonna be like no we need to
get out of here before sundown yeah i was like guys the
hint, guys.
Let's just do it.
It was so frustrating because there was a few things where
we knew what we had to do, but we couldn't figure out how to
get it to work.
Like, we just couldn't figure out, like, the mechanic.
And so then when we used the hint and it was told to us,
we're like, damn it!
Like, we were doing that!
And then there was a walkie-talkie where, like, we phoned it
in and be like, we don't understand the hint.
Oh, we're like, oh, yeah.
There was one hint that was lost in translation.
And we were like, what?
So we have to be like, we have to walkie-talkie in and be
like, hi, could you like explain, please?
Like, you rephrase this.
Oh, no.
But we only use three hints.
We only use three hints.
Isn't three the number that you were giving us, like, a
maximum?
Yeah, that was the math.
No, they said we could do it more, but they're like, oh, but
you won't be on the leaderboards.
I was like, guys, we're not going to be on the leaderboards,
guys.
And then it became competitive.
Yeah.
I was like, I want to be on the leaderboard.
Yeah, and then I was like, Doki, you just like took in all
of Faker's energy, and she's like, I'm not using that for
this.
Yeah, yeah, they're like, you could, yeah, they're like, you
have Faker's.
I was like, I'm not using it for the fucking escape room,
guys.
But the leaderboard, Doki, the leaderboard.
Oh, good lord.
We can't even be public that we're there.
We can't even, we can't even acknowledge it.
And now we'll never know.
They're like, okay, so the thing is, like, They have this
like giant wall of like photos of everyone that completed
it.
We can't even be on that wall.
We can't be on that.
Of course, yeah.
Like, what's the point?
I know, I should have had them take a photo of me just
holding all of our plushies.
Yeah, so you could be on the wall.
That probably would have been it, yeah.
And then it would have been like, wow, that one girl beat
the Titanic room with just plushies by herself.
I was just like, it's like they don't even know we were
ever, it's like, we were never there.
So like, just use all the hits, guys.
it's like we were never on that titanic yeah oh god yeah so
i can't believe we forgot we almost forgot about the escape
room i think i wanted to forget about it i used too much
brain power so you couldn't be storing anything to the hard
drive it's so true like i we were not kidding when it was
like 80 math related questions i was so checked out oh god
that's crazy um next time time mousy will bring you to the
next escape room and then no you know you're gonna be on
your computer and you're gonna have the calculator for us oh
yeah that's true i will yeah they're in person yeah you're
gonna be there in person everybody will think i'm so smart
yeah yeah i did that so fast you just read off of google on
the leaderboard baby so cute someone's like Who knew that
Tantanic was full of map puzzles?
No wonder so many died.
Yeah, that was a real oversight.
Oh, my God.
Why did they do that?
Are they stupid?
Oh, geez.
Oh, my God.
You know, Jack would have survived if he'd just won his
timetables.
Yeah, next time.
I feel like the first thing we got to do when Iron Mouse is
there in person, we do an escape room.
We've all four of us.
See if we're better.
See if we're better than our managers.
Because I'm pretty sure our managers actually...
have like the managers and staff do another at the same time
we'll see who comes out first i think the guys i to be i i'm
going to be honest you guys i think the managers are going
to win i think okay ideal we get 3d tracking we go into the
escape room we turn into content that's true no oh and also
we should get the easiest room and they get the hardest so
it scales you know like it's like it's like we're in plat
lobbies they're a grand master their top 500 and we're
bronze okay we deserve to be in the elo we are and no it's
like you've ever seen those videos where it's like five pros
versus a hundred kids in soccer or something we're the
children yeah honestly that's let's see if we can find like
96 more vtubers just to do this with us how many vtubers
does it take to beat an escape room wouldn't you like to
know i love the one part of the escape room where i was like
we're climbing through this and both of you guys went no
we're not and I went yeah we are oh yeah you literally went
into the room and was like that hole it looks like it's
gonna open and yeah you guys were like no I'm not you're
crazy I'm like no we're getting on our hands and knees there
I know it oh my god it was not great it was it the floor was
so hard it was fun though oh yeah and then like someone has
to crawl to the back and i was like i'm not crawling back
i'm staying in this yeah you like volunteered me you were
like get in there all right i'm not it i refuse to do math i
refuse to crawl yeah hey look i got the last puzzle right
okay and the i helped us i helped us escape when it matters
that was great no yeah we need mouse there next time please
be our math person yeah i will It's like right out when the
moment we get off the plane, we go straight to an escape
room We're already exhausted like I've been on the plane for
like 12 hours or something Yeah, yeah, they were like it's
time I have to do mathematics use that brain of yours.
It's time How many escape rooms can be back two in a row
before breaking?
One just one not point five.
Yeah Oh my god, that was our career career trip the ones we
the stuff we can say the stuff We'll be able to talk about
the other half, hopefully sometime before the end of the
year.
The stream, when everything is revealed, we'll let Mousy
talk about everything.
We'll let...
Yeah, yeah.
You get the whole stream.
You get the mic.
Yeah, and you can show off your mask skills as well,
presumably.
And then we'll be the ones showing the pictures.
We'll be like, here's what we did here.
And then we're like a PowerPoint presenter and stuff.
Like the...
You know, like the card girls?
Welcome to my TED Talk, yeah.
Yeah, like the...
Who wants to be a millionaire and we're opening the
suitcase.
That's us.
We're the case ladies.
Yeah, we're the case ladies.
And then our mouse is the host.
But it's just like, so we went back to T1.
And then we went back to T1 another day.
Yeah.
We were there a lot.
We were there.
We lived there.
It's like we lived there.
Heaven forbid a woman have a hobby.
I tried to make other people that buy more T1 stuff with me,
but it didn't work.
I tried to make Jennifer Roberts spend more money on it.
Yeah.
You nearly did convince her.
I did.
She was like, I don't need more jacket.
is like, but what if you do?
What if you do?
You were trying to get her to buy a floor length like trench
court parka.
And I was like, Jen, you don't need that.
We live in Los Angeles.
But what if?
But like, what if there's a snowstorm in LA?
Then you would regret it.
Heaven forbid.
Like, you don't need that.
Like, Doki, the devil on her shoulder going, but you'll
never get it again.
You can only get it in Korea.
You don't get it in this story.
Good God.
Because Jennifer Roberts' husband works at for League, works
for Riot.
So she, I was like, yeah, but Riot doesn't have this.
Riot doesn't have this market.
God.
Not in LA.
Yeah, I get it here.
Faker himself touched this park.
Faker was part of the creative process.
Faker looked at it one time.
Faker modeled this jacket.
The light from this jacket bounced into Faker's retinas.
Holy shit.
He stared at it one time.
Oh my God.
Oh, yeah, that reminded me.
I was also so mad that we missed out on the Mean and Green
because they were raffling off of a 5090 that was signed by
Faker and the NVIDIA CEO.
I was like, I remember when you guys were like, oh, we could
have been there to help you win that.
Yeah.
It would have been like six or seven, six, seven tickets on,
but for just you.
Yeah, because yeah, we were like, I was like, I could have,
I could have almost won.
crap that's side crap apparently it's valued a million
dollars because it's signed by both that's your time and
fund right now yeah it's you know my both faker and the
NVIDIA CEO so it was like valued a million dollars and
wasn't the person that won it said like oh I'm so happy to
get this because I have like a a 2060 yeah 2060 you were
like you're gonna use it and not for it yeah I was like it's
okay we'll just go next to you we got another one you guys
know yeah yeah like it's like how could you use this it's in
family heirloom at that point yeah put it in a museum god
yeah i would put it in a frame it and like you know like
those pokemon cards where it's like like oh god like framed
is my psa 10 graded and video graphics card psa i get a
graded and everything like oh it's like in a shadow box oh
my god like in the shadow box like i mean like This is my
I'll pass this down for generations my family heirloom Oh my
god That's so dear.
Yeah So all in all what have we learned on this trip about
ourselves and the wider world?
I can't wait to go again Yeah, and have mouse yeah, and then
mouse to be their person.
Yeah, yeah, don't worry.
Don't worry that when everything is revealed Mousey will
have so much stuff to talk about.
It's just unfortunate I love it.
I love it.
Other stories.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm so glad.
We're happy to share some of the stories and also all the
bars too.
I wish you guys were there at the bar.
So it wasn't just, it was just three of us drinking eight
drinks.
I believe in you.
I was not okay.
I had, I was, I took a sip.
You had a long whole flight after that, so you were probably
fine.
I took a sip of everyone's drinks too.
Just to like see the taste.
What was my best?
I did not like yours, Amelie.
Why?
It was like a creamy look like.
No, it was because I just didn't like the coconut and milk
mixture.
I just, I was not a huge fan of coconut, but like, um, uh,
Mousy one was sweet.
I like Mousy's one.
It was sweet.
Um, and then Ryn's one just tastes, it was pondergranate,
which was similar to the faker string.
So, uh, so, yeah.
This reminds me of someone.
yeah but like it was good it's just like I wasn't a fan of
the coconut uh and the milk texture of it that's fair that's
fair I just don't like all that next time so but it was
really pretty it was really pretty oh yeah it was very
pretty it was a good job I think if you like coconut milk
then you would like it it's just unfortunate I didn't like
coconut milk that's okay yeah it's a acquired taste for sure
it's very tropical it's very like pinnicolada e yeah yeah
which I love a good
Oh my god, next time we're in Korea, we all go to the bar.
But also, I will be scared because the chef knows ENB
tubing.
Oh, we're going to have to be careful.
We're going to be gone.
Yeah, yeah, Mouse and Doki have to be completely silent.
Yeah, yeah, we all wear like masks and sunglasses too.
I think I can, I'll just talk in a slightly higher voice and
then Rin because they're gonna have to work on her American
accent and then we'll be safe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What are you talking about?
This is completely indistinguishable from your average
Midwestern man.
No, oh yeah.
I just remember the chef was like, I was so, because he had
to come to our table because he was like, I was so surprised
because the foreigners normally won't order V-Tuber stuff
because, you know, foreigners would order like anime
characters.
So he's like, I had to know who ordered all these V-Tubers.
Oh, God.
wait a second bro i want to freak out he's like interviewing
you he's like what's your favorite youtuber i like really
deer in headlights i was like oh she lost her voice
yesterday she can't just give the stock response like oh
i've seen a hololive one time yeah yeah yeah so we gotta we
definitely gotta be careful though we definitely gotta be
careful it's so funny yeah i just I was just like, I don't
know.
I just thought, I don't know.
I don't know why I thought we were so safe.
Like, we're in the, like, an Otaku stream bar.
Like, we're never safe.
We're never safe.
They're too fair.
There was, like, all live merch everywhere, too.
So, I was like, I feel so safe here.
I was just like, oh, God.
I was like, I feel so safe.
My identity will be okay.
Next time, we'll go around.
We'll make sure to finish the job.
job we're gonna finish the job true um i'm looking forward
to another stream together with you guys especially the
gaming stream hey yeah we gotta figure out what to play yeah
there's like a ton of new games that have come out that look
really that's like three months to decide on something yeah
we'll figure something out oh yeah oh yeah and also uh meet
your ohhi thing too i only was you guys on meet your roshi
and like i mean all at once would be fun but it would kind
of be this but maybe like individually would be kind of cool
yeah it's like our little podcast thing yeah we just yap i
just ask you some cute questions and we mostly just yap for
an hour it's it's pretty we could play we could play this
game guys i just saw it it comes it came it's coming out
this week oh oh that looks fun i'm in town until monday so
if you guys want to do something before monday always doing
stuff look at her she's always doing stuff i know and i
leave when do you come back after monday i'm there for a
week so it's monday to monday i'm gonna do the week after
for me i'm fully booked next week and this week because i
just posted my schedule this week and next week i have i
have to cram for my tournament for next week oh yeah so like
it's it's all street fighting a little stream on the
weekends for us on saturday or You can go on walls.
You don't like practicing in the background.
Okay, let me look at Loki.
You could have a tiny little blue.
Good for us.
Just a little.
You hate us.
Okay.
Maybe I can on Friday.
Or Thursday.
Thursday or Friday.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can.
Okay.
I want to check my schedule.
I'll see.
You guys have to come up with the time.
I'm on Hammer Time right now.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm on HammerTime.com.
The kill trip is...
surreal don't worry don't worry let me break down very
easily i don't suppose we could schedule this at a time that
isn't uh quarter past one in the morning for me folks uh the
problem is that how early do you wake up grid i'm trying to
get better how early do you wake up because if we look at eu
time we might ours will be a late stream and then rin will
be an early stream we'll have a we'll have a what i mean god
with the jet lag anything what time is it because This is
what we did this today.
That is 11 p.m.
at night.
Okay, but what time do you wake up, Red?
Give us a hammer time.
Hopefully before then.
What about...
Give us a hammer time.
What about this time?
The thing is that...
What time is this for you, Mouse?
What do you have to say?
Guys, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
What time is...
What is...
Okay, what time is...
You got this?
I'm typing.
I fucked you up.
I have to retype this.
I...
Okay.
Any second now.
It's almost there.
I'm just doing it.
I'm doing it.
Okay, what time is...
Tell me, I can probably do it faster.
No, no.
What time is this?
That is four in the morning.
Okay, maybe not four in the morning.
Maybe.
My name is mine.
That's why I was going earlier, but then I think it's too
late for...
Maybe we could do three hours later.
So then you have to wake up at seven, like how I woke up at
seven in Korea.
Oh, dear.
That would be 11 p.m.
to me, but I live on JST time, so I, uh, even though I'm
East Coast, I live on JST time, so like, I sleep during the
day.
All right, so we could do, we could do this time.
If that works, Bryn just has to make the sacrifice for all
of us.
I was going to say, yeah, it's going to take a miracle, but
we might be able to pull this one off.
We could pull this off, guys.
We could do it.
We'll, we'll, we'll interchange.
I'll check my schedule.
I'll see what I've got on the next few weeks One person has
to suffer, but then it's me that's 11 p.m.
for me It's 11 p.m.
for me too!
Joki just got on one of us has to suffer and then
volunteered me!
Well, I guess we all gotta go back to Korea.
I'm on the fireplace!
Omeli, it's not just you.
Brin has to be up at 7 in the morning.
That's so cool.
I love being up at 7 in the morning.
I think 7 a.m.
is worse than 11.
I'm so awake at that time.
I like how Alba Lee was like, this is so bad for me.
And everyone's like, how do we have a seven in the morning?
No, it's fine.
I'll do it.
I'll do it for nobody else but you girls.
I love you so much.
But just for you.
What time is that for your, for Doki and, um, I'm literally
West Coast too.
What do you mean?
Oh, it's awesome.
Yeah.
Wait a second.
You're like a gamer.
I stay up late.
You're a D gen.
Don't get me wrong.
I am a D gen.
It's just, I'm cool of anything.
Like the great thing for me is that any of the times work
for me.
Actually, you know what?
I just realized that whole Korea trip, you made fun of me
for being so old, but you got dye put on your gray hairs.
Yeah, because I, oh, oh, you're going to make fun of my
genetic disorder.
Oh, God, here it comes.
I have had gray hair since I was a kid.
I literally had it since I was like a little kid.
for like 20 years and then my parents lied to you and was
saying oh you just you just think a lot that's why you have
gray hair because your brain is so big but as a child i
would then try to stop thinking i don't think that's what my
parents would want yeah so but it's because i legitimately i
have like my jeans make it so that i don't produce enough
like pigment for my hair so i i that's why i get like gray i
literally have i have i've been dyeing my hair since i was
like three Aww.
That's so cute.
And then I would, and then I would be like this little, like
little kid with full head of gray hair.
If I don't do it, people will like, what's wrong with her?
Just means you're wise, Shirley.
Shirley.
I love that.
You just think a lot.
They literally in the cutest way said, you over, you're
thinking too much.
Calm down, small child.
Yeah, they're like, oh, you're just really smart because you
have a big brain, so you're always thinking.
And I was like, I'm just like, why?
So that was a lie.
The gears in your head are brr.
no it's just I'm literally I just have low on ink I don't
have enough ink in my hair to fully print it out really cute
actually yeah that's why that's why she tried to make fun of
my medical she's my medical that's wrong she's smart and old
he was born old I was born old Benjamin Budden born ripe at
the age of 56 I'm I'm a Benjamin Bun and Kitty East right
there.
But just the hair, though.
Next time I see you, Doki, I'm going to gift you some toner.
Like a printer.
Printer toner.
I get the ink and paint it on my hair.
Like Copic marker, like refill.
Just color my hair.
Yeah.
Apple Security's going to be like, what the fuck is she
doing?
What is she trying to take aboard?
All right.
I'm going to put this time into my schedule then.
Okay, 11 p.m.
we all set was that but what date I could do it Saturday or
Friday the third the third the here I'll do it I'll do it
are we doing Saturday or Friday don't worry princess I got
it all right I can do either Saturday or Friday I think
Friday would be better for me Saturday I have a convention
too so I'd be like okay all right all right this is okay
here's the here this one this is the one Friday that's still
Saturday that's Sunday for me she posted Saturday two times
okay here she's trying her best I'm doing my best over here
I'm trying to make it better to work under pressure she's
getting you know she has to get better at it yeah she Doki
wants me to have Yeah, I won't drag her down with me.
They'll get there.
Lord knows.
This right.
All right.
Friday at 11 p.m.
PST.
Yep.
So we all win technically.
We're playing the same.
I'm going to ask my thumbnail artist right now.
Yeah, I'm going to ask my thumbnail artist right now.
Can I again?
Someone shout.
Oh, damn.
So when my chat was like, but I won't be there.
Well, too bad.
That's a real shame.
That's what the vibes are for, baby girl.
This is the time that works for all of us.
Almost all of us.
Your chat's like, that doesn't work for me.
Too bad.
You're like, oh, it's not what we want, Timmy.
East Coast stays losing.
I'm sorry, guys.
Hey, you won for this stream.
You won for this stream.
Yeah, my expense.
Sorry.
You will be sorry.
I still I still love the fact that Amelie was like 11 p.m.
That's so I'm getting fucked here And it was just sitting
there was like, Hey, I'm just a girl.
I need my hag needs her beauty sleep You guys will be
getting deranged drama though.
I hope you're welcome because I've never streamed past 10 p
.m Oh, me too.
It's like a gremlin.
You're gonna either get really tired calm like like onesama
or you're gonna get nothing zero everything phases you way
too much too fair I feel like I encountered gremlin anomaly
a lot when we were drinking I feel like I already yeah no we
were they kept giving us so much alcohol they're like do you
want alcohol and I was like it's free though it is free I
was like yeah I do give me give me a good point yeah it was
like almost every dinner They're like, do you want alcohol?
And then I'm a Leah and I were like, yes, all the time.
Like, I will never forget being mid-poor of that second Ube
picture and someone going, be careful with that.
The hangovers are bad.
It was like, it was like the music started getting louder in
my head.
Yeah, I actually had to take the picture away from her.
Just me, okay.
She was not, she was like getting way too drunk at one point
and I had to take the picture away.
And then I was like, please don't give her more.
Like, I don't remember.
I legitimately don't remember what it was, but at one point
you were so drunk and you were saying something super wild
and I literally just like took your picture away and I was
like, you cannot have more.
You put your hand on my shoulder at one point.
That's enough now.
I literally had to cut her off.
I had to cut her off.
That was how bad it was.
She was not fine.
I was fine.
no it's bad when i had to stop you because like usually i
like embrace that shit like i like relish in the in the
chaos but like you said something really wild that actually
had to stop you wait what did i say i don't remember i the
thing is i was also drunk so i don't remember i just had to
take it away from you never invite us back no no no it's
when they taught us taught us something and didn't tell us
what it meant.
And then I said it really loud.
And they were like, don't say that, don't say that.
Oh my God, yes.
Oh, I was like, why?
What does it mean?
It was, okay.
I remember.
We should be saying this now that they, if they had that
reaction.
We were at, yeah, that's what it was.
I remember now.
So we were talking about like, what Korean words do you
know?
So I was telling them like, oh, like back in high school,
middle school, I used to go to an international school where
there was a lot of Korean students.
So they would teach me like Korean words and phrases.
And I was telling them, I know a lot of Korean swear words
Because obviously that's the first thing you learn, right?
So I was like...
See, I wasn't that drunk I remember!
Yeah, but only after you thought about it for a very long
time Because...
And then, so...
They were like, what words?
So I, like, said it quietly Because it was a really bad
word.
It was not a really...
No, dear.
I still don't know what it means!
It's not a slur.
But it's, like, considered one of the worst words you can
say in Korean.
So, I was like...
I know this word, like, oh, oh, and then Ali was like, what
is it?
And I said it to her, and she said it so loud.
She was like, you didn't say what it was?
She was shouting it out loud.
She's like, and then, like, and then the staff was like, oh,
no, no.
Because we can't come back.
We were in a restaurant, and then people, apparently, like,
a table was looking at us after she said it.
And she's like, what did I say?
I was like, it's a very bad word.
It's a very, very bad word.
And I was really scared.
I was like, oh, what kind of bad words?
Like, oh, no.
Yeah, that's when you, like, you're not allowed to say
frickin' goblet.
I know, I was like, huh?
I was like, there was a reason why we were whispering that
word.
Okay, in my defense, this was right after our Pokemon
conversation when we're all trying to pronounce the Pokemon
words.
So I'm in that mindset of like, wow, different phrases that
I'm learning.
Play too close to the sun.
Yeah, she's like, I'm gonna repeat all of them.
And yeah, yeah.
It is basically, I can't say it now, obviously, not on
stream.
I get the impression made, you shouldn't say it ever.
But if anybody watches like Korean esports players or
anything, it's like one of those things they say like when
they're really, really mad.
It's like, it's one of those words when they, you know, like
when they type but typing or seeing it there when they get
tilted so it's one of those yeah yeah so that's bad so yeah
that's when she took my ube picture away and then that's
when i and that's when i probably for the best in retrospect
i didn't know i'm i'm just a white girl you have to preface
those things by saying don't repeat after me you know you
can't tell me those things no self-preservation
re-engamer words.
I don't believe you have the audacity to say heck in public.
It wasn't a slur.
I will say it was not a slur.
No, that was not a slur.
I was like, did you just teach me like a slur?
I was like, no, no, no, no.
It's just like, it's just like a swear word, but it wasn't a
slur.
But still, because we were in Korea.
It's so bad to say it in public outside of like gaming.
I was really, worried i was like just so everyone knows
those words you shouldn't say in front of people you don't
allow i'm like yeah like crap or vtuber yeah on that note uh
it's about half past one piece so i'm like oh yeah yeah no
worries that's a good time to call it here guys i had a
great time yeah for chatting i almost said thank you for
games yeah thank you for all the games every single one.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you for waking up early too.
Super early for Mousy and super late for Rin.
So thank you guys for doing this time.
It's so hard to sync for four of us.
I can't wait to go to that.
Can't wait to see all of you guys in Korea next time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Next week.
Well, please, I'll do it.
And then I can't wait to see you guys on Friday.
I'm excited.
I'm excited too.
We're gonna be little guys.
We're gonna be little gnomes.
I'm in dread, but in a cool way I'll see you guys later.
Okay, make fun hanging out with everybody.
Bye.
Oh my gosh.
That was fun hanging out with them guys.
Um, really fun, uh, stories to tell.
I didn't show a lot of the photos because I, I keep
forgetting to.
oh okay um i don't know i i'll show you guys these photos i
didn't uh i didn't show it uh on stream while we were
talking because i was so preoccupied telling stories but
i'll show you guys um um i'll show you guys uh these photos
i took from the the t1 facility um oh my god it's so it um i
didn't tell you guys this but it was so funny because um
even though like amalee rin and mousy didn't really know t1
or faker their managers did though like um jennifer roberts
and zoe were like our like huge league fans but it was so
funny because uh it was so funny because when we got there
the staff went straight because i was on that requested the
tour so they're like oh she's the one who's the big fan so
she they like went straight to me and it gave me exclusive
baker merch like three sets of the same merch and and then
like the two managers looked at me and was like that's for
all of us right and the staff was like that's for her and i
was like i was like i was like yay
i don't know what i'm gonna do with three set i should have
given I was just like, yay!
Alright, I'll show you guys.
It was really cool.
I was like so thankful because I was just like, me?
For me?
So...
Let me see, I can show you guys more photos.
I'll show you guys more photos of the... I think the T1
facility was just so fucking cool.
Because it was a private tour.
It was uh in biblical levels of greed right there it was a
private tour and then i was not expecting all the stuff
there that i was getting i was not expecting it i was just
like yay uh let me see i'm sending it to myself right now i
want let's see uh i took picture of it here oh there it is
all right let me save this real quick okay so it was so this
in particular this so these these fake it was three sets of
this so all of these are exclusive Baker merch that you
can't get anymore.
They're discontinued.
They are discontinued Baker merch that you can only get at
LAN.
I don't know which LAN, but they gave me three sets of this.
So, so one is a holographic card.
One is a trading card.
And the other one is a enamel pin.
And I got three sets of it.
And, um, it's basically, they discontinued merch that you
can't even get anywhere anymore so it's like um yeah so like
and you can only get it at land yeah excuse me sir that's
great and you didn't share i was just surprised it was in
the moment all right it was it was in the moment to be fair
they um one managers was with me when they gave me the merch
and then she saw it and then the the staff was like you want
one so then they gave he they gave her one card and then
they gave me the rest they even gave her the entire set they
just gave her one card and then he's like all of it is for
you i was like oh
it was just it was in the moment i got caught up in the
moment i got caught up in the moment
so I was really appreciative of the staff for sending this
to me I really I really appreciate okay so I need to show
you guys this one I know it's all about t1 but this was like
this was my like um what's the call this is my safe haven
like and so omelette and randy got to go to olive young the
t1 stuff was literally like uh this was my my time you know
it was it was it was they were when they were at like olive
young uh me and another staff member i didn't really want to
uh i didn't really care much so um um so like because like i
don't need to stock up on a lot of them since i don't go out
as much as i do so i was like it's fine i but I know like
Amalia has to go out a lot and stuff and also like um and so
she's always traveling and everything but I'm like I'm just
at home it's all right so I was getting like bing su and
stuff with a staff member while I was there so um so I
didn't I didn't go to all of young so I was just I was
eating desserts and stuff with the staff member I was like
free dessert?
Yay!
So I was eating bing su.
Um, just hanging out with the staff while, uh, Rin and
Amelie were at all of Young.
So the T1 thing was my thing.
It was my thing.
Alright, so this one was fun.
I'm gonna check if they're, I'm gonna check if this photo is
safe to show.
Um, so, um, they had T1 signature fragrance.
So, Here, each one, is there's the journey, the self-esteem,
the strategy, the friendship, the victory, the gamer
perfume.
Yeah, get it, fragrance?
Yeah, so I was so upset because the HQ shop was closed on...
that day because it was a holiday and and so i couldn't when
we went to the other shop we had to go to this different
shop that like the pc the t1 pc bang um and but they didn't
have the perfume so i like i beg i didn't beg i didn't i
request i asked if they could um if they could get me
because the after it was open the day after so I asked the
staff if they could get me the victory
so and they said they can they can for me so they've
actually I have I have the victory perfume I'm gonna put
that on before my Street Fighter tournament I'm gonna put
that on the floor of course so I have I have it now I own
the victory fragrance.
What else?
What else can I show you guys?
Oh, yeah.
Here.
For those who are T1 fans slash faker fans, I know what
games they play.
I took photos of their game collection.
We were allowed to.
are the games they play they would have they have a giant tv
um they have a giant tv where uh where it just like where
they play other games um where they play other games and
stuff and this is soccer behavior so they have apparently
the staff was like i was like oh what fighting games they
play because they have the fighting sticks since i can show
you guys a picture so they have a on there and i asked them
i was like oh what games do they play and they said oh they
like to play super smash bros during breaks and stuff um uh
let me see if i can where is it um oh yeah here's a pic i
have a picture of where baker does stretches on the floor
the exact floor okay i took that photo as like a funny ha ha
thing but i
I would like to say I took the photo as like a funny ha ha
thing be like this is where he did his stretches guys it was
ironic it was irony it was it was not an ironic it was irony
it's all right here we go sure it was it's sure it was so
Let me double check.
I need to double check because it does have a reflection,
but I need to see if I'm not in it.
So this is like their, this is their room where they hang
out.
There was a, the floor, like, it was like the second, it was
below the rooftop and this was like the floor.
So I saw the fighting sticks and I was asking them, oh, what
fighting games they play.
And they were saying, I don't know if you can play Smash.
You play Smash Bros.
with fighting sticks.
Yeah, you can, right?
So they were saying like, Oh, they usually play Smash Bros.
up here.
And I was like, oh, that's pretty cool.
You know, the industry's secrets and everything.
Okay, here's the...
Guys, this is the floor.
Guys, this was the floor where Faker works out.
Okay, to be fair, they told me to put the plush on the floor
as if I was there.
So, this is where Faker works out, guys.
This is the floor where he does the stretches.
This is it.
It's not creepy.
So, oh yeah, here, I'll show you guys the karaoke booth too.
They literally built a booth just for karaoke because they
sit like, like I said, they...
um they they love karaoke and so they have this little booth
there where they go belt out songs i guess post league games
if depending if they win or lose i guess it'll be like big
so see there there it is there's you see that little mini
that's the disco ball so they literally have there's a big
room and this this is the small room um and uh yeah the team
does karaoke and stuff uh So because like they love karaoke,
but there's no karaoke areas There's no karaoke areas Near
the HQ base So they built these little karaoke rooms for
them So there is two karaoke rooms, one small one Which is,
this is a small one And there's a big one, I don't know if I
And there's a big one too So they would, it was literally
post-match They'll go karaoke in their little room I thought
that was really cute what else what else I'm gonna look at
the oh yeah this is also Faker's chair I'm really sad on
this chair you might remember this chair from like
promotions and stuff
this one there's also Faker's chair because I don't know if
you guys can see it but on the right side of the chair
there's Faker's signature on there
Yeah, this is also his throne.
Yeah!
I- I did- I- I was too scared.
I was so scared to sit on it.
I only went, sat on it without hesitation.
Because they're like, oh, you can sit on it.
And I was like, oh, I don't know.
I was just like, I was so scared.
I was like, I don't know.
Oh, am I worthy to sit on this chair?
And I was like, I'll sit on it.
I was like, am I worthy?
And I was like, I'll sit on.
And she's just without hesitation.
I hesitated because I was just like, I don't know if I'm
worthy.
Baker's sat.
It's just a chair.
It's, it's Baker's chair.
Who is it a fan girl for Faker?
Guys.
Who?
Faker is literally, if you ask any esport player, and I
don't know if you ever saw this video.
I think it was EWC.
It was an EWC video.
And they were asking all these esport players, all these
esport players, who is the best esport player in the world?
And everyone would always say Faker.
Everyone would be like Faker.
He's the, he's like nearly the definition of a winner.
He is what every pro player Aspires to be He literally He is
a winner He is a champion And that is why I space jammed
Faker I have a tournament next week I'm going to space jam I
need the winning aura He is him Exactly Exactly.
He faking it, faker it till you maker it.
Okay, by the way, next, I'm so fucked, guys.
I didn't want to talk about more of it because, like, I'm so
fucked in the next week's tournament.
I'm learning a new, I'm learning a new, I'm so sorry, guys,
for those who are wondering if I'm going to play Zankief in
Honda.
I am not doing either.
I'm playing my.
I'm learning from the ground up.
I've literally been trying, I've been trying to figure out
my, like, I, you know how, like, last week, last week, um,
I'm sorry, I know, I'm sorry, I became the person everyone
despised.
I, I, but, okay, so, you know how, like, the other times I
played the tournaments, I, like, I don't have Asset, I just
wait until the last minute to start training, um, because,
like, Honda, I had three days to learn Honda, but I was in
the beginner tier, I'm not in the beginner tier, guys.
I am not in the beginner tier.
I am not.
I am the tier above beginner.
I am where Emily was.
I am where.
So I literally, I was either going to be Ingrid or my.
So I asked my coach's chat and I asked him, what do we, what
do I do?
Because I wanted to be the most degenerate player.
Because I was like, I'm so fucked.
I am so fucked.
I was just like, I'm so fucked.
So, so I was gonna try Ingrid because everyone's saying
Ingrid is like very broken and everything and then um and so
um but then apparently my is still pretty degenerate still
my is still uh pretty fucking degenerate so um so my coach
was like you should play you should play my instead of
ingrid because like she's still really really good um so so
i was like okay i'll learn my and then that like i was i
knew i was like i'm gonna get my ass kicked i want to make
it at least look like it i had a fighting chance you know i
so so they were like so i was just like i'm gonna get my ass
fucking kicked but i don't want to look like a huge stop so
i've been i've training since last week but to be fair it
was like one to two hours like every other every other day
so uh while i was in korea so i had to wake up at like seven
in the morning and just fucking okay shy didn't believe i'm
gonna okay i'm gonna call it like we're gonna call him out
on stream too but he was like day one of coaching he was
like i didn't know if i have anything to work with and
they're like he was like are you sure you don't want to go
back to honda like he was like think it's GGs, I think.
But I was like, no, shot.
Every day, every day, I just need to marinate it.
I just, I was like, I just need to marinate, you know, every
day I improve because I need the information to marinate in
my head.
And so like the next day, he was like very surprised.
He was just like, I didn't think I would get this far.
Like I, I was like, you didn't believe in me.
Because, like, I got a, at one point, I got four, at the
end, I got four-game win streak, and then he was, like, on
day two, and he was like, I legitimately didn't think we
would see a number this high up by, like, I didn't think I
would even see,
I didn't think, I didn't think I would see you get that many
wins in a row.
I was like, you, I told him, this is, this is, I was like, I
did this out of spite.
I just, I knew you didn't believe in me.
I, I did this out of fucking spite to prove you wrong.
Anyway, I'm against Kony.
I'm against Kony, Bricky, and Ricky something.
I'm sorry, I forgot his name.
He's the new guy that I don't know.
So, I'm sorry.
Ricky Peacock.
I'm against Ricky Peacock, Kony, and Frick.
I'm so fucked.
I am so fucked.
I'm against an FGC player.
I'm not.
I literally, Kony didn't reply.
I literally messaged Kony the moment I found out I was
against Kony.
I was like, please be gentle.
I literally was like, please have mercy.
I'm just a little baby.
I, i was like i was just like please have mercy he didn't
reply
so that's why i know he's not gonna have mercy on me i i
little sister
so um so this was a tournament i couldn't tell you guys that
was participating in like i I said like I had to wait until
Capcom announces it um but hey at least fight I told feisty
I was like just carry me feisty I don't think I can I don't
think I can do much like last time feisty I'm so sorry I was
like to her I was like I I don't think I can clutch this one
out that this is all on you feisty this is all on you I told
her I I'm getting my ass beat feisty I'm fucked I'm
time but this is also why i had to like train super early
because i was like i knew i was gonna get my ass kicked but
like i said um i just i just didn't i just didn't want it to
look like a slaughter i i i didn't want to i didn't want to
look like a slaughterhouse as if like i i spawned in and
it's like perfect ko so i was like i want to give a fighting
chance you know i want to give like an attempt to survive
because like i said usually i just like that this is why
this is why i bought the victory perfume this is exactly why
i bought the victory perfume guys i just i hope this will
help me
Yeah, just use the perfume.
So, yeah.
That's next week.
I also have an Overwatch tournament on the same day.
So, so yay.
But yes, I have to practice Street Fighter.
But yes, I will be up.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I know.
I, guys, I had.
Guys, I know.
Guys.
i guys i know i know how everybody feels about my guys i
know but i need this guys you know you know you know how i
play these games guys you i'm so i'm so i know i know i know
i know i became the evil the evil minds.
I've joined their side.
She's desperate.
Modern mind, too.
Guys, I'm desperate.
I need this.
I'm desperate.
I have no shame.
You know this.
You know I have no shame.
I pick any character.
That's the most abusable.
I said, they're like, okay, because like, someone that's fun
or someone that's gonna get the job done and I was like I do
not care I want to get the job done like I was like I
because like fun would be Ingrid to get the job done my and
I know because like he's like oh but you do Honda or a Zayn
Geep and I was like the stuff I did on those two characters
are not gonna work against Koni or Bricky or Ricky Peacock I
I don't know who Ricky Peacock is, but I know the things I
did to think the cheese that my cheese strats My cheese
strats will not work against those three new
So I I knew It was not gonna work in that tier Pick a top
tier claw master they was super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, you would destroy me.
They would cheese me back.
I'm not, I can't, I can't cheese them.
They'll know my strategy.
Because the thing is, how I cheese is that I keep cheesing
it until it doesn't work, but I know it's gonna stop working
the first time I do it.
It's gonna stop working.
They know the way of cheese.
They're probably gonna destroy me out of way, but like, at
least It won't be it won't look as bad
I opened the first replay on CNC round start X fan drive
rush She might be cooking chat It I will say I am doing
combos This time Like Baby's first combo more like Fluffy
King's thank you with a super chat thank you Thank you it's
more like Baby's first combo It's not just It's still four
to five moves but it It's so baby's first combo Um Also Also
Shine does not Okay so you know in Honda My entire strat was
to Uh Was to like just use up all my energy or whatever it's
called The drive bar Because like Honda has a thing where he
keeps repeating the thing He's repeating hitting Looping it
And it always works It always works But that but like what's
that word but that's like a really bad thing to do on my so
that every i kept i kept emptying my drive far yeah i was
just like i was like i'm gonna do it and it's i was like you
have a chance to stop you literally it's like you know how
like i use you you shout out what move you're doing and i'll
be like i'm gonna use up all my energy and he's like stop
doing i'm gonna burn out But like I have I had a chance to
stop before I burn out, but I just I I commit to it And he's
like and he's like because like I would say it before I do
it And he's like you are aware that you are burning out I
was like you are aware that you're burning out that you're
going to burn out but you don't stop
Like...
Because I would say it before I do it.
I know.
I know it's a problem.
I think.
Let it ride.
I can't stop.
Won't stop.
Yeah.
And then I still...
I still...
I still want some matches.
I'm silver, by the way.
I'm so...
This is not looking great.
This is...
I hope by before the tournament, I at least get to Platte.
I really do hope so.
Because then it wouldn't be like...
Silver my against it.
Diamond slash Master Ryu.
I just...
I hope I can get to Platte by the tournament.
By the end of the tournament.
I hope that happens.
Because it would look so sad.
It would look so sad.
Do I'm against like a...
Koni's... Koni's a Ryu player.
The last time he played Ryu, he was in Diamond.
And I've never seen Diamond before.
Yeah, if they lose, they beat up a baby.
Exactly.
It'll plague their conscience.
Yeah, the coughing baby.
keep being sober it's more cinematic I was flat as Honda I
was flat yeah so we'll see how it goes I don't know what
he's gonna play I know he played Rio during the last slam um
he played Rio during the last slam and um I know what the
other two played too So, uh, so we'll see how it, how it
goes.
No, Giv, I was stuck.
I was stuck in gold.
I could never get past gold on Zang Giv.
I was legitimately hard stuck there.
Honda was the first time I've ever seen, I've ever seen
Platt.
And that was three days on, I was three days on Honda.
And that's when I first saw Platt.
But if you, for those who've seen, I've never seen my
gameplay on Honda.
cheesiest shit there like I spammed I did not know any
combos that was why I was like I can't play Honda because
how I played Honda was like I just abused every cheesy strat
that I know on Honda to win and it works but I know it won't
work when I'm against like those three yeah yeah I knew it
wasn't gonna work when I play against them so that's why uh
I I'm not risking it i'm not risking it on honda because
like honda's a honda's a skill check basically yeah you just
gotta learn to i can't my is the safest it's the safest
thing my has one tournaments it has one tournaments it's the
safest choice um i don't know know if i can i don't think so
i don't i don't i've already committed some guys i woke up
at 7 a.m for like three to four days straight to learn my
i'm not throwing that away i'm not throwing that guys i'm
not throwing that away i woke up at seven in the morning
guys this is where i i've already committed enough time and
committed enough time for this i'm in too deep exactly i am
in too deep to back out now
all right i'm gonna see other photos i can show you guys um
that i'm allowed to show you guys um i there's so much stuff
in my suitcase but i i can't i can't be bothered to unpack
right now i'm sorry That's always the issue.
It's just like, Will Doki unpacked.
Remember when I was like, guys, I'll show you guys the stuff
I bought in Japan.
It's been a while.
It's been a while since that has happened.
And she never unpacked.
Let's see.
I'm trying to see what else I bought that I can show you
guys.
Um...
I wish I took the picture of like the booths and stuff.
It was just so funny at the historical village.
I was like, why is there Nike?
Why is there Nike Latin?
It was so funny because it's like the backdrop is like
historical villages and stuff.
And they want to make sure it's like, you know, it's...
You know, you're not really immersed in the area.
It was like you walk in and there was all these like World
Cup booths and stalls and stuff World Cup stalls selling
like World Cup merch.
So like like the and then like the the jerseys and
everything And and like we are in a historical village.
So it was so surreal.
It was so fucking surreal To see that it was so funny.
It was really funny I was just like where am I?
I got karma so hard though when I had to for the Pokemon
village because I was like joking around with like Amelie
and Amelie Rin and Jennifer Roberts and me and like because
they're like it's not fair we have to go we couldn't go
there like they were saying the server and then I was like
thanks for the suggestion guys I'm gonna ask staff to take
me there right now and they're so they're like I'm so happy
for you so I was like wow guys hey guess who's going there I
got karma so hard because I got karma so hard because I
forgot to put the drinks the drinks in my checking bag and
had to throw it away I was so sad it was like it was karma I
glowed it too hard it was actual karma um i want to show you
guys the photos i took of the pokemon park it was cute it
was really cute
instead um let's see i can show these oh i'll show this too
all right um
here all right i'll show the last couple photos before i
call it for the day i did not expect to have an extra stream
this week uh because it's i will say it's like the twitch
streamer way where a lot of streams are not scheduled
they're impromptu they'll be like i'm gonna do this the next
like you know but um i'm the youtube way like the from my
corporal experience so i'm very like old school corpo
experience where i was just like this is what i'll be doing
each day and this i'm gonna stick to that schedule and then
they're like we're gonna do it this i was like oh i skipped
my but i have a schedule though oh my god i have a schedule
though i
but i i really want to do it i really want to i want to want
to play games with them and everything too.
I'll bond with them more.
I feel bad for Rind the most.
I feel bad for...
I feel bad for Rind the most only because we have to sync up
to like three different time zones.
And then I'm sorry, EU goons.
But you guys might sometimes get the short end of the stick.
Yeah, she's taking the bullet for the team.
you might have to take the short end of the stick there all
right let's see i'm double checking all right i'm gonna save
these i'll show you guys some final photos
i'm saving it
all right there's some extra last photos i'll show you guys
um This was the...
This was the Poke Park.
So there was like...
Like I said, it was literally the Japan...
If you guys ever seen videos of the Japan Poke Park, that's
literally like what it is.
But like a very small scale.
We literally finished walking around it in like 15 minutes.
That was how...
But like there was a...
There was a...
Wait, a giant line though.
There was a huge ass line this place um for like a 15 minute
walk around so uh apparently the staff had to get there at
10 in the morning to line up to grab a reservation ticket
and then we could only go in at 2 so um because there was a
huge line for the reservation because like it's like
reserved like it's like so so like i said we had to go in um
of course uh uh so so she picked up the ticket at around 10
in the morning and then we had to we had to go there at uh
at two to actually be uh to actually go in because that's
the time the reserve time and everything so that was
basically the whole thing and uh there was this too i'm
double checking the photo real quick It was really cute,
though.
Like I said, it was really cute.
Like, if you ever seen the...
If you've ever seen, like, pictures of the Japanese...
Japanese Poke Park, it's just that.
But, like, 5% of it.
5 to 10% of it.
Yeah.
This is all Korea, by the way.
So, this is the Poke Park.
It was really pretty, though.
It was really...
It was really cute and everything.
And...
This is the photo I took at the airport before I...
You can tell I opened it and drank it.
This is the photo I took of the drink before I had to throw
it away.
My karma right here.
You can tell.
I opened it.
The worst part is that I didn't even chug it.
I just, oh, and then, and then I was like, I'm okay.
I wanted to keep the bot.
It's so cute.
I didn't even drink it all.
I just didn't want them to have it.
I was like, and then I was like, can I take one last photo?
And they're like, yes, you can.
I gave them a parting sip.
I They wouldn't let you pour dough I had to chug I was not
chugging This guys Guys I cannot chug it I knew it I wasn't
gonna chug it I got It was It was literally cold brew coffee
And sparkling apple juice It was not a great combination To
chug It was not mixing cold brew coffee with sparkling apple
juice in a chug.
I weakness.
Chug it, you coward.
I'm sorry.
I just was not strong enough for that.
It was just not possible for me.
Oh yeah, this one.
It was some bing su.
It was so good.
um this is this is a different type of bingsu where it's
threaded bingsu with honeycomb i got the milk i got the milk
uh option um with the honeycomb on it it's bingsu so it's
shredded ice uh it's it's just shred it's just like it's
like an ice comb but better and it was so good oh it was
really it's like shredded ice but it's threaded and it's
like with like uh milk uh milk syrup and um honeycomb on it
too it was so fucking good oh my god um oh yeah here to all
you faker fans out there
that was at the cafe me feed me more faker r oh she
that's a shirt that's a shirt Guys, that's our own sheet.
That's...
That's crazy.
Alright, let me see if I have any more to show you guys.
Um...
I could show you guys food.
I'll show you guys this.
This one was so good.
Let me see.
I'll show you guys one picture of food, because I I don't
want to...
torture you guys too much I need to find a picture of food
that's not that that doesn't oh I ordered both okay so I
didn't say this too but the first day when I tried we tried
to go to a PC bang and it didn't work out I you know like I
was still I just had shine like teach me stuff on his screen
because I couldn't download Street Fighter like I said by
the time the coaching session ended it like I was there for
two hours and by time the session ended, I only downloaded
10% of Street Fighter, so I was like, we can't do PC bang.
I have to, like, use the PC that we did for off collab for
the Street Fighter thing.
And so, so, um, so while it's there, um, just, I had a staff
with me.
Like, we always have to add, like, someone there with us
just to make sure we don't disappear.
Like, we don't lose our way.
Um, so, um, so, like, poor staff member that to put up with
me being there early.
Because I was like, I need a trade for Street Fighter.
Um, can I, like, you pick me up at, like, 8 a.m.
Before our actual workday starts every day.
It was, like, it was three days straight.
It was three days straight.
And she had to be there for my, like, Street Fighter 6 labs.
So, on the first day, on the first day, for her, it was
always her, too.
It was always her that was with me and she's a poor staff
member
So Um So on the first day since we were we were trying pc
bang there was like Bold doc there was so i was like i had
to order it like you could you know like you know like
Eating at a pc bank i was like i have to experience this
like the the pc bang the korean pc bang way Or I'm just
eating Bulldog noodles while trying the game.
So while I was like getting coached by Chad, I was just
like, just listening to him.
Because I couldn't play, you know?
I couldn't play.
So I was just listening to him eating my Bulldog noodles at
8 in the morning.
Like the staff was like, it was like this early.
You're going to eat Bulldog because I was like, can I get
because like I was, you can order on the PC.
so but obviously I had to use her card and then she was like
you want bulldog in the morning and I was like yes I was
like she was like confused you're like are you sure you want
to eat bulldog at 8 in the morning I was like I'm very sure
that I want to eat bulldog at 8 in the morning I so I'll
show you as a picture I gotta do what the locals do the
authentic experience guys it was very authentic there see it
was so authentic guys look at that my my bulldog noodles
with the cheese it's not even mixed yet but I have to mix it
yourself cheese sausage and spam I was truly it was real
gaming hours It was at 8 in the morning.
It was the trap single.
This looks like a struggle meal.
The spam I added in.
I was like, I have to have spam.
It was a gaming meal.
I had to do what the locals do at PC bangs.
What's...
It's literally what you...
It's literally like...
the PC bang way I had to like like embrace the lifestyle you
know like I I was like when will I be in the Korean PC bang
again when in Rome I'm here to embrace the culture embrace
the PC bang culture when in Rome do as the Romans say it was
so good it was so Don't judge me.
It was fucking delicious.
You're all just jealous.
You wish you had this bulldog.
I was so sad I wasn't able to do the traditional, you know,
like the whole traditional
bulldog 7-11 or like convenience store bulldog video.
I wanted to make a, like do a video ironically with like my
dohi plush and then i was like i was like i have but then
like the one time i finally i was gonna do at the airport
because um because i had no time i wanted to like uh i
wanted to like obviously you know buy a bulldog get those
like uh pouched drinks and stuff with the ice can with the
ice bottles and stuff and then also like you know buy like
the cheese and the sausage and dip it into the bulldog and
like um and just just do a funny ironic video like you know
because like all They're like everywhere on YouTube.
And I was going to do it at the airport because that was the
only time I had time.
And I had like two hours till my flight.
Got there.
The only company that I didn't have was Bulldog.
I was so mad.
I was like, this is the day.
And it was literally the one day.
It was the one convenience store.
that did not have Bulldog.
They have the fucking K-pop Demon Hunters noodles.
Like the, what was it called?
The collab noodles?
Um.
Oh my god.
Is it the Shin noodles?
They have Shin Ram Yun.
They have the K-pop Demon Hunters Shin Ram Yun noodles.
But they didn't have Bulldog.
I was so sad.
I was gonna I was gonna do it.
I was gonna do the classic Bulldog convenience store noodles
thing.
And you put in the microwave and stuff.
You put the cheese on top and then put in the microwave and
everything at the convenience store.
I had it all planned out.
And they didn't have it.
They just...
They did not have it.
I know.
It was crazy that they didn't have it.
yeah
it was like the day I left too it was like I had two hours
before my flight to leave Korea and they didn't have it I
was so sad I'll show you guys one more food place picture I
didn't have to call it I have to go to the Apple store to
pick up my iPad uh because I don't have an iPad and I have I
basically used my Miku sponsor money so tomorrow's a sponsor
right and it's Miku I literally so I could stream the Meeku
game.
Because I didn't want to play it on my phone because the
screen is so tiny.
You know how the screen is so fucking tiny?
And stuff and it's like a rhythm game.
So I didn't want to play it on a phone.
So I was like, I might as well get it.
I need an iPad anyway because I need to like do writing
stuff.
Like I have to write stuff for merch and stuff.
So I was like, it'll be convenient.
You know, like it pays for itself.
So I had to go to the Apple store to pick up the iPad that I
ordered yesterday.
So, yeah, now I'll be prepared.
So, I'm doing the Project SETC guy, Miku, Colorful Sage,
sponsored tomorrow.
But, like I said, I have to pick up the iPad.
If it works, it works, you know?
I literally get an iPad now.
Alright.
out to make sure it works.
Oh, my gosh.
I haven't played Project Seca in so long.
I think when it first released in English, right?
I remember I got a sponsor way long ago.
Yeah, now!
Now it's a... That's true!
It is tax deductible now!
Alright.
Here.
Look at that.
No, I'm a Leonie and I bought it so much because we're
always drunk together.
somehow we were always drinking next to each other so
because we're the only two that was like it's like we can't
drink up so much so Emily and I were always like drinking
because it was free alcohol so like fuck it let's go it was
so good this was really good um yeah it was uh we were like
drinking buddies uh i haven't by the way i like i have not
drank in so long too so i was literally like it was i mean
it was free i like soju i like soju is flavored and
everything so i was fine with that because like soju um the
flavored ones you can't taste the alcohol so like i like it
so um so luckily i was drinking alcohol that was like oh so
the fact that it was three of us and i we had seven
cocktails between three people like because we wanted to get
it with everybody so we had to be fair it didn't help I
could have ordered my drink and also I could have ordered my
drink and also like one of the girls but I was like I want
faker so I was like my drink so faker it's a drink instead
of my drink and like rinse drink so I was drinking because I
thought it was funny so we had to try and drink all seven
between three of us because we didn't want to waste it
obviously things I would do I bought a little I told you
guys about my little faker plush.
I thought it was funny.
I mean, when will I ever get to go to a T1 facility again?
That's the thing.
I thought it was such a huge opportunity.
They're literally, I know I don't talk about T1 a lot or
like, like, I don't know, I know, but they are the best
esport org in the world.
They are like real, like, I recognize real I you know they
are the number one esport org in the fucking world I
recognize real when I see it they do they have their own
private chef all right guys I'm gonna call it here um oh I'm
gonna call it here I hope I'm glad to be back guys I am so
glad to be back back it has i know i i hope you guys i hope
you guys didn't forget about me i'm happy to be back home i
have been traveling a lot i do have to travel again next
month for the concert as well in la so i'm sorry everybody
but we're making lots of memories there's a lot of really
fun announcements in the works because like we're doing a
lot of collabs with iron mouse Emily and Rin to lead up to
the announcement of whenever it's going to be announced um
and uh it's going to be really fun and I'm really looking
forward to the next couple of months guys it's a lot of
stuff is building up to something I trust me guys I swear a
lot of stuff is building up to something amazing and uh it's
gonna be really really cool uh so yeah I can't wait to
stream again I the shit was scared I was gonna forget how to
stream and everything um I just can't wait for Mousy to be
able to tell her side of the stories.
I know it was just mostly like me, Amelie, and Rin yapping.
Um, because it was just unfortunately, like the stuff that
she was there for, it was all under NDA.
So, um, the only thing that she was there for that wasn't
under NDA was the T1 tower.
It was, because like, the thing is, it was limited to three
people only allowed inside.
It was so funny.
It was limited to only three people who were allowed inside.
side so like it was so originally gonna be like me amalie
and rin and then obviously like rin self-destructed got sick
so um her manager took her place but also her manager was
also a really big league fan um and but uh uh uh our mouse
and her manager team really wanted to be in the tour too so
we were allowed to uh basically uh do a video call um do a
video call to like show the tour around and it was so funny
because uh Jennifer Roberts really wanted to see it be part
of the tour but she wasn't allowed to because like the tour
it was a private tour that was only limited to like three
people so she wasn't allowed to so she sneaked herself into
the video call like being like I'm Iron Mouse 7
Just sneak your way into the call to be like I'm also you're
part of the staff team to look at this It's so funny.
We're like Jennifer, Jennifer Roberts, just join the call.
Just join the call
We're like we like we're like we're like I was like telling
Amelie Tell you can tell Jennifer Roberts to join the call
like we're like we're like video call We're like not
recording we didn't record any of this.
We're not allowed to record any of it.
I was like, we're like filming this anyway.
Like, it doesn't.
I mean, like, she really, really wanted, um, she really,
really wanted to see it too.
So I felt really bad.
So I was like, just tell her to join the call.
And then she joined the call.
Because like, it's got, it was, like, it was being shown,
video shared anyway.
So like, it doesn't really, I thought it doesn't really
matter.
Cause like, um, So I was just like, all right.
Just a plus one.
Oh, where was that?
What was that?
Oh, but yes.
Can't wait for Mastabilia to share more of her stories.
And, you know, I'm glad we were able.
Because, like, we were so worried.
We didn't want to, like, exclude her, too.
Because, like, you know, a lot.
We did a lot of stuff where it was just us three.
And we want to tell her some of the stories as well.
well so we're really thankful that mousy was able to join us
today and uh listen to like you know be part of some of the
stories and listen to like what we were doing and stuff so
we really appreciate it because you know mousy uh uh mousy
you know mousy's such a busy person so um she didn't have to
be here so i really appreciate that she did uh join us today
and just to hang out with us and also like be a part of you
know uh just to hang out with us and uh be part of like the
us because even though she wasn't there physically she was
there with us in spirit uh it was fun like nobody expected
her as like the fourth member because we're like there's a
secret fourth member and then we're like we're like i was
like you should quote retweet this and just like here like
we took a photo we took photos like oh my god it'll be so
funny like be like surprise she was always there it's like
that humpty dumpty meme in pussy boots is like i was always
there like
We took a lot of those photos Where it was just us three And
then Mousy was there But like I said A lot of those photos
are NDA So we were only able to show photos That we are
allowed to show Like
Yeah Um Any guys I'm gonna call it here I need like I said
To go to the Apple store As always everybody Stay hydrated
Posture check Get up And move around To get that blood
flowing And if you stay up for me Head to bed you deserve it
I'm gonna head off now I'm glad to be back bye bye everyone
bye bye